Oh sweet baby.
Jesus.
Here we go.
We are,
we actually laugh so you that I can hear my own laptop.
So I know it's live now.
It's a feature I trust,
not even myself.
Now it's a feature if fucked it up so many times I've decided to strengthen
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by tank.
If you go to ting.com forward slash no,
that's the wrong one.
rogan.ting.com is the update URL,
rogan.ting.com.
Uh,
if you go there,
you will,
you will check out what [inaudible] is all about.
It's a,
uh,
an ethical cell phone company.
They are selling you the very best mobile devices.
Uh,
on the android platform.
They have the Samsung Galaxy as two.
They have the,
the galaxy note to the s three,
the galaxy s three.
They have all of the high end android phones,
which are pretty bad ass.
I have a that Samsung Galaxy s three.
It's a magnificent piece of equipment.
Um,
so you're,
you're not like a,
you're not going to be starved for technology dealing with cheaper prices.
And in dealing with a no contract situation and instead what they do is provide
you,
um,
cell phone service on the sprint back where a backbone.
So you know,
dealing with like some mom and pop a cell phone distributor.
It's an excellent cell phone network.
The sprint network,
one of the biggest ones in the country,
no contracts,
uh,
no,
no ETFs,
no bundling a ride along services,
no overage charges.
If you use more than they thought you would,
you just pay for whatever you used.
You'll also get credits on the unused service,
which is,
I love this.
If you use less than you thought you would,
tink drops you down to the level you hit and credits you.
The difference on your next bill.
I mean that's like a sweet as you can get with a big corporation.
I love it.
And everyone can do this.
You know,
this,
this doesn't,
it doesn't have to be just one company that functions like this.
There's plenty of money to be made.
You just don't have to be a total douchebag about it.
And that's the,
that's the philosophy behind tank and that's why we support them.
If you go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot com you can save 25 bucks off of
either services or phone from a,
a really bad ass company.
Go Dana white phones here,
like the refurbished three 70 votes.
He loves a little flip phone.
He texts really quick with his thumb.
I don't get it.
I don't know why he would even be interested in trying that,
but uh,
that's his,
that's his move.
Um,
so go check it out.
We're also brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is one of our newest sponsors and what Squarespace is.
If you go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe,
you can,
uh,
check out what they have to offer,
what it,
what it is is a website that's set up so the lay person can divide,
can design and build a website.
The way it's set up,
all the templates are very intuitive and they have a bunch of different examples
that you can say of what your website could look like if you try it this way or
that way.
And it allows you to do,
which wasn't really possible just a few years ago.
A few years ago,
you had to like hire a guy.
I knew html,
you know,
you had to learn how to use a different software packages.
A dream weaver was one of them,
right?
Yeah.
There was all these different really complicated programs to learn how to not
complicate it.
For me,
if you're a web designer,
you're like,
dude,
it's fun.
Clone Bakunin and I could show you it.
Shoe Mofo,
Robin Hood does learning code.
Nope.
Pad and html.
That's all I used.
Do you actually built them back in the Disney,
right?
Yeah.
I still like prefer that.
I would just go in and just put some,
a harass in there.
And so why do you like,
do you like it?
Yeah,
for the satisfaction.
It's just like,
it's kind of fun to do it that way.
It's just,
it's,
I just don't think it's that hard.
It's pretty easy to do.
Yeah.
But you went to school for that?
But it was when I took the first class at my college,
the first class they ever had on internet,
it was called multimedia production and design.
And it was the first time they're like,
well,
this new Internet shit,
it's catching on.
So we'd better start having some classes,
you know,
about the Internet,
designing for the Internet.
And I took the first class of the first year,
it was like so stupid.
They had no idea.
The teachers didn't know how to do anything.
You know,
they were like,
we're,
we just learned about this to this internet stuff.
Teachers who've been teaching for 20 years possibly teach you about the
internet.
They pretty much just like,
well,
there's this thing called flash.
Uh,
it's from Macromedia and uh,
it's on version one.
We should probably look into that.
And so you must be able to really appreciate something like Squarespace.
The fact that they make it so easy,
everything's easy now.
I wish,
I wish I enjoy it because I actually hate doing websites now.
It's just because like for other people it's the worst thing ever to do because
like you'll design this whole website and they're like,
ah,
you know,
I don't like the purple.
And then so that means you have to like change every single little table and
stuff.
So the cool thing about like Squarespace is that you could just put a template,
like if you just have you,
if you want a website that's just like,
hey,
I have a,
you know,
a store that I want to advertise,
a small company,
you could just pretty much get a template,
put it all the information down so you'll at least have some presence on the
Internet.
So it makes it easy.
Here's one of the cool things about Squarespace.
If you go there,
you sign up.
You don't need to enter in a credit card.
All you have to do is just try it out,
start building a website.
And then if you decide,
okay,
I like it,
this could be my website,
I,
this is a good product.
Then you decided to purchase Squarespace,
Squarespace.
Just use the code Joe to Joe and the number two.
I Dunno why Joe and the number two Joe too.
So that's squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe and the offer code is one word,
Joe.
And then number two,
you should do that and get 10% of their fucking businessman.
It's some wacky Shit Joe to who's going to remember that?
It's Taco Joe.
That's what it needs.
It's yeah,
it is ridiculous.
They'll say no one's clicking through.
I'm probably because no one can remember that.
Yeah.
Cause if they're just probably going to Joe.
Yeah,
either way.
Doesn't matter.
It's good company.
Good,
good product.
Uh,
and uh,
excellent.
If you are looking to design your own website and it's satisfying to do so,
go check it out.
You Dirty Fox were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n,
I t.
And if you use the code name of Rogan,
you will save 10% off any of the supplements.
Um,
people who have heard this podcast before.
You know what on it is?
If you don't,
it's essentially a company that sells all things that make your body better,
whether it's uh,
foods.
We sell a hemp force,
which is a incredibly nutritious protein powder.
It made out of hemp with Maca and cocoa in it and Dan Carlin's on the podcast.
So we can go into the history of why this hemp is illegal to grow in America,
but yet legal to purchase.
It's non psychoactive.
If you have questions,
it won't make you a test positive on a drug test.
It's just a,
it's just the plant material.
No,
no,
no drug but excellent for your body.
Super Easy to digest.
It also has raw cocoa and Maca in it.
And A,
we sell a lot of cool shit like that on it.
We sell coconut oil,
we sell micro toxin free coffee,
we sell buffalo jerky bars.
It's all Himalayan sea salt.
I don't know if that's really supposed to be good for you.
I don't know.
It sounds bad ass.
It's like killer be hunting again.
Probably not that much better than regular honey,
but sounds bad ass.
So we have it.
Um,
we also have things for kids.
We have um,
uh,
green vibrance for kid and Nordic jellies,
which are,
um,
their fish oil,
a gummy bears and gummy worms for little kids.
So it actually,
Mcdonald's fish bites with the McDonald's fish bite chicken mcnuggets better
fish now at Mcdonald's with a dipping sauce.
You filet of fish without that white stuff.
That tartar sauce is just dog shit.
It's just not good at all.
But together pretty damn tasty along with that sugary been and you know,
they put sugar in that fucking button,
that button.
It's so bad for you.
The filet of fish buttons like extra sugary.
Anyway,
no extra sugar he had on it.
Go to Oh and and I to use the code name Rogan and save yourself 10% off.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
let's cut the bullshit here.
Cue The music.
Brian.
Dan Carlin's here.
We're going to learn some shit.
We're going to find out what the fuck really happened and how we move forward.
The Joe Rogan experience.
[inaudible] we went old school with the music folks because
Dan Carlin's here of hardcore history in DC.
Common Sense.
You have two podcasts.
Yes.
And I'm telling you,
man,
this is a very few people that have been requested as many times as you buy the
fans.
I owe you for having me here.
I had no idea.
We had much crossover on the audience apparently quite a bit because people
don't,
my message board or super pumped about this,
people online is super pumped about this.
I think now more than ever in this country there's a uh,
learning a yearning rather to understand how the,
how we got here.
You know,
when you look at the financial crisis and you look at our ridiculous actions
overseas and you looked at it like,
like,
wow,
there's a lot of kids that are growing up right now that are in their twenties
and thirties and they,
they,
they look at this mess that we're in as a society,
as a culture,
as a,
as a race really is that the whole human race and how the hell did this all
happen?
And because of that,
I think there's more of an interest in history today than at any time.
I remember like young people being like really interested in history and uh,
when I was younger.
But it seems like there's like a more of a clamoring for this knowledge now than
I think I've ever heard before.
Hi helps when the history channel's doing monster quest and ice road truckers
kind of leaves a vacuum for some of us to sort of just shoot through to drive
you crazy when you watching the history channel or it's,
I don't know if it does.
Part of me starts to think that yeah,
it opens up.
I mean,
you know,
we were doing some work a while back with some of these production companies in
La and New York and stuff that had to,
you know,
we'll,
we'll get this guy from the history podcast and we'll develop a show around him.
And I'm in these meetings with these guys and it's like every question just
kept,
can we,
can we make this a little more broad?
Can we make this?
And eventually,
you know,
you're going to have Dan Carlin searching for monsters is what they were looking
for I think after,
so we're sticking with the podcast.
I think,
I don't think they think there's an audience for history and yet I think that
gives us an audience for history.
There's no place else for those people to go.
They're stuck with me.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting what people think that people
I want to and don't want to see because there's obviously the Internet where you
know your podcast is very popular.
There's a lot of very popular podcasts where it's just people talking and you're
getting hundreds of thousands of people to download these things with just
people talking and you look at the amount of people that are tuning into your
average television show on a cable network and it's pretty commensurate.
Isn't that shocking?
That's crazy.
It's not so much that we're all doing so good.
It's the television is really doing so bad.
Well,
in trying to paint that broad thing,
they've lost any semblance of being exceptional.
There's just nothing.
That's a good way to,
that's a great way to put it.
By the way,
I'm loving this fungus free coffee that we blend.
We blended up with a grass fed butter.
It's tough to find that grass fed butter.
I've actually started ordering it online.
I would miss the fungus,
but I'm finding I'm getting everything I want.
Right.
The fungus has just given you a headache apparently according to there's a guy
named Dave Asprey.
He runs bulletproof exec.com.
And uh,
he wrote the bulletproof executive and his idea about bulletproof not being
actual bulletproof,
just being that,
you know,
it's rock solid nutrition,
rock solid,
you know,
management of your body,
all this stuff.
And one of the things that he found out was,
um,
the,
uh,
the mycotoxin and coffee issue that so many people weren't aware of.
You're going to work and you just,
you know,
drinking that coffee from the coffee machine,
the coffee maker that,
you know,
Bob May,
hey Bob,
when's the Howells his coffee 20 minutes ago.
No one's really thinking about what the fuck is in that actual coffee.
But apparently there's quite a bit of coffee that has fungus on it and unhealthy
mold and that's shit can apparently be very poisoned.
And you know,
our industry functions on this.
So without this,
we're just dead in the water.
So,
but I mean comedy writing,
I mean there's so many different people that create things.
He was coughing,
he was doing a show on like the history
of stimulants or whatever,
and it was going to be like a nine part series because there's so much,
I mean that like you said,
the whole creative side of so many industries without the coffee and other
stimulants,
you know,
where do you go Saturday night live is not around,
without exists or something like that.
Along those lines we'd,
yeah,
it's,
it's funny when you think about the fact that the Boston tea parties is
actually,
is that really what started people off drinking coffee in this country when
they,
I don't think so.
I think that's one of those kind of myths sort of things.
I think first of all,
if you're addicted to tea,
you're not,
you're going to just switch because you know,
somebody put a little tax on it.
I mean we can see how that works.
A little tax on something,
you just find a way around it.
But how hard was it to get tea back then?
Was it,
you know,
it was,
it was a hell of a commodity,
but I don't think it was that hard to get it.
I mean,
smugglers,
how hard is it to get something you're not supposed to have today?
So Ti was like a big commodity.
Go to a big t dealer and behind the scenes,
you know,
and just have some guy,
they can get the t on the side smuggled in from French Canada or something.
Isn't that bizarre?
When you hear about like salt used to be worth a lot of money still is in the
right places.
You take away the salt and you watch the price go up,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
But I mean the idea that people would go to war for it.
Like could you imagine we're headed to Africa right now to go get salt?
Like that was a,
that was the reality at one point.
I read a whole thing about how Afghanistan might be all about lithium deposits
and stuff and you're going,
oh,
50 years ago nobody wanted lithium for anything.
I mean now it's just one of those things where it,
God,
we've got to get ahold of Afghanistan and those lithium things will dry right up
Afghanistan.
So rich with other things as well.
Natural gas,
not just the minerals natural Tyler or ways to mind though.
It's like mining out in a patchy country.
There's inherent risks.
Well yeah,
that's a lot of folks who don't understand,
uh,
Afghanistan like tougher conversations with people about it.
You can't really compare it to any other country because it's not really a
country.
It's like a series of warlords and they control various areas and it's through
the whole country and there's only like a little bit of city life.
There's like,
what are is?
What's Kabul?
Is that the big setting?
Kandahar,
places like that.
But they are all these are all tribal PDX and so it's like I'm Indian country.
I mean there's no other way to describe it.
You get in there and you can't make,
there's no one to make deals with the two controls Logan and you have to deal
with this chief and all of a sudden you don't have to deal with the other
teacher.
He have to like the first guy and 10 miles away,
you're out of your district and they're all playing a little game.
Hammad Karzai's winking to us in one hand and tell him the domestic audience
something on the other hand and it's like double blind rear end,
you know,
I mean we just don't play those games as well as the people in Afghanistan.
Yeah,
well that's a strange culture.
I remember,
um,
when McCain was running for president and Obama was talking about going into
Afghanistan,
it was one of the few times that I really,
uh,
I really respected and Mccain for the way he did it,
he would say like,
do you understand Afghanistan?
It wasn't even being condescending.
He was like,
this is like run by this.
It's basically where the same way it was when Alexander the Great was a lot.
And look at the terrain.
If you're a military guy,
just look,
it's,
it's like,
yeah,
it's like Sonora over
there,
but,
but worse.
And you know,
it's one thing to decide.
You want to fight a war in some flat desert place where all of our air power is
gonna make a huge difference.
The terrain is like beyond the Martian,
crazy,
crazy terrain.
And so you look around and you just go,
look,
the Russians in the 1970s and eighties,
they might not have had the infrared stuff like we do,
but they were pretty Dang sophisticated and willing to kill a hell of a lot more
people and they couldn't manage it.
So it's really scary now that they've turned in so many parts of the world to
drones for these difficult missions.
And,
uh,
the,
the implications of using drones on people,
it's a very,
it's a very strange
sort of a conversation to start having because it's step one on a multistep
process where eventually these drones are going to be intelligent things that
are controlling themselves and they're going to be searching out crime and,
and shooting people from the mountains.
I don't know how you stop that though.
I mean it's like saying I don't want to have tanks because look where tanks are
going to go.
The problem is,
is that we treat them differently than life people.
It's like if,
if you said to yourself,
well if he wouldn't go in there with a human pilot and bomb the place,
cause it'll look like Nixon bombing Cambodia when you shouldn't then don't do it
with drones.
Right.
But if you're going to use him for occasion and if we're at war with somebody,
you're going to want the drones.
We don't want to use everybody.
Yeah,
but you're not going to want it if you say,
well we couldn't bomb Yemen's a tribal territories with a,
with a bomber and a human being,
that would look bad.
But we can do it with a machine cause well there's no Americans there.
Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
And that's why it becomes a strange sort of a conversation to have and it's
going on in Pakistan,
but we're not really at war with
no worries.
You're going to start using them in Africa now.
Yeah.
They're flying them in African now.
They were going to use them on dormer.
They were gonna.
They were gonna use,
he was going to be the first target of a,
of a drone and on American soil.
That killer that is still to be w did they,
did they confirm that,
that they were going to use a drone to go after that guy believe so.
I should,
I shouldn't.
I absolutely wild if they really are.
How do you spell his name?
Dormer DOR.
Mer.
Was that going to be a decision and what level do they make that decision?
Is that,
is that the,
the La Sheriff's office decides that or you got to call the president?
I can't imagine the White House would let that happen even if the sheriff's
department wanted to,
because then all of a sudden you have to answer all those questions.
They're not answering now about is it okay to kill Americans with a drone on
American soil?
Well then all of a sudden that becomes a moot point,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
Apparently.
Well,
this is on Gizmodo,
uh,
ex cop Christopher dormer now at target for drones to Riverside Police,
chief Sergio Diaz,
joint leader of the Task Force,
uh,
signed with finding dormer has confirmed and is quoted as saying,
we're using all the tools at our disposal and a third vague conference.
That doesn't mean he's using drones.
Well,
wait a minute.
Do you know what that makes me feel like,
and this is perverse,
I have a little bit of a perverse sense of humor,
but if the guy was going to die anyway like he did,
I almost wished that they'd done it with the drones at the local level so that
this whole thing explodes into a national conversation.
Do you think it would,
I don't.
I think people don't know except that he was,
he was obviously an evil Doraemon.
So what is the Burger?
The position it puts Obama and all of a sudden this whole thing,
you're ducking now you can't duck it anymore and you're not using it against
terrorists.
Well,
it depends on your definition of a terrorist,
but you know,
I mean,
any old murderer fleeing the scene of a murder now is open to,
uh,
you know,
no judge,
no jury,
no due process.
You know,
we knew you killed him.
So I mean that's a,
that that's going to happen to you.
I mean,
we're going to hit that fine line at some point.
Well,
they've already started assassinating American citizens that are in other
countries that they believe in doing things illegal.
The government won't confirm it,
but everybody,
it's an open secret.
It's a,
it gets real tricky when someone does denies the rights of,
of citizens than someone who's empowered.
Denies their rights because w what are you then,
if you're in power and you're denying their rights,
as soon as you step in and deny people do processed,
deny people lawyers to die people,
why would you ever want to do that?
It's a real question.
So when things get passed,
like the National Defense Authorization Act allows the government to
indefinitely detained American civilians and they don't have to do anything.
They're not required to notify your family.
They're not required to arrest you.
They're not required to.
You don't.
You can't,
you don't have to get a lawyer.
They can just lock you up when you see shit like that.
Does that drive you crazy?
Oh yeah.
And people always say to me,
they say,
well,
you know,
why are you defending the terrorists?
What you try to explain to people is without the due process,
there's no confirmation that this is a terrorist.
The only way you know it's a terrorist is when some court somewhere determines
upon looking at the evidence that this person is a terrorist.
Once you can kill somebody on the suspicion of being a terrorist,
well,
we're all under suspicion of being a terrorist under certain conditions that
someone wants to deem a mistaken identity situation.
You know,
or mean how many guys are named Omar or Mohammad or you know,
I mean,
well,
how about in this dorm or case the,
the cop shot up two different cars that were the wrong color.
Perfect example.
Yeah.
You the,
the idea that the government should have special powers that regular human
beings don't.
That's crazy.
Well,
they have that now.
I mean I think they already do because your government to take it to the next
level and decide that you're going to deny the rights of people that you feel
are guilty.
Well,
who are you and how do I know that you're infallible and how do I know that this
isn't corruption?
How do I know this isn't a personal grudge?
It's not like you're dealing with an organization that has a spotless record
over the past,
you know,
200 years where they're the most ethical human beings to ever exist and people
from other countries come to them for,
no,
we've caught them a lie,
but $1 million.
Oh,
you had could.
We had a committee hearings,
which you cannot even imagine today,
which shows you how much things have changed.
In the 1970s we had the church committee hearings in the Pike Committee hearings
where the government actually on television exposed everything the CIA had been
doing since the end of the Second World War.
The assassinations and all this kind of stuff.
The crown jewels are what the used to call those secrets that were exposed on
television by congressional and senatorial committees.
It just shows you what happens when there's no oversight and if stuff is too
secret to have oversight over,
you're asking for trouble.
There's too many ways human beings can justify going beyond the rules and
there's always a good reason and you hear it today.
I mean the waterboarding thing,
as a perfect example,
we prosecuted people at Nuremberg for having an attitude that we have now,
which is,
hey,
if they're terrorists and you can save lives by torturing people.
Isn't that an ethical dilemma where it's worth torturing some guy,
you know,
is bad anyway in order to save lives.
I mean,
if you could have prevented the two towers from falling down by waterboarding,
a couple of bad guys,
isn't that worth it?
And that those ethical dilemmas lead you off into the weeds really quickly in
history shows that over and over again.
It's,
it's very doubtful that it's helping either.
It's very doubtful that you're really getting that kind of key information from
people by throwing water down their mouth.
You know,
I don't,
I just,
I don't know if if torturing people get them to tell the truth
gets him to tell you anything you want.
What about would you,
and I wish I could quote it at length.
It's a wonderful line going back hundreds of years where somebody says,
would you abrogate the laws in order to get the devil?
And the other guy says,
no,
I would.
I would stick to the laws because if,
if you abrogate the laws to get to the devil,
you take away the only thing that protects yourself eventually.
And that's what this is.
People say,
well,
it's okay to go after this to get to terrorists.
What makes you think one that it'll stay with terrorists and to that what a
terrorists is,
that definition won't change.
The Bush administration was calling these people that would light,
you know,
car dealerships on fire in the middle of the night when there was no one there.
Ecoterrorists you're going to drone those people,
right?
What are you going to do exactly?
Where does the line get drawn and who gets to decide anti fungal coffee
proponents that might get a little hyped up,
but those motherfuckers grown those people.
Yeah,
it is.
It's a strange time because the amount of uh,
ability to the,
to spy on people and to extract information from your email and your cell phone
and you know,
they know your,
your di gps at any point in time,
but yet we're still just human beings and human beings have to be protected from
their own instincts.
We have to set up a system of government that has fail.
Proof stops where you can't get past certain levels through,
can't,
you can't do certain things.
You can't act with impunity.
He can't be a king.
You know,
there,
there has to be a due process.
There has to be representation.
You have to be able to get a lawyer.
You have to have some,
you have to,
as an American citizen be able to state your case.
Well,
here's the fly in the ointment though,
and this is,
this is almost like the founding fathers tragic flaw in the system.
In war time,
the rules are thrown out the window,
right?
In wartime,
the government is allowed to give the,
you know,
the congress is supposed to decide when you go to war.
Then once the war's going on,
the president has,
you know,
they say extreme constitutional authority as commander in chief to,
to run the war anyway they want.
But this is all predicated on the idea that the war has an end,
right?
This is a temporary suspension of normality.
What do you do in a war?
Like in a war?
I'm using air quotes.
So what do you do in a war that has no end?
Who's going to sign a peace treaty with us on some battleship to end this war on
terror?
This is like saying you don't remember the Bush administration for Awhile was
toying with the idea.
They thought the war on terror had gotten sort of a bad name.
So they were going to do a little marketing move and change the name and for
like five minutes they were calling it the war on violent extremism,
which I thought was a great line because that really showed how ridiculous it
was.
When's violent extremism over who's going to sign the the end of the war treaty
and surrender to us and the violent extremism or so we can return to a normal
American system with checks and balances and where the president didn't have,
you know,
extreme authority.
That's the problem is that we're in a situation where it's war time and it's
going to be war time forever unless somebody declares it over and if they
declared it over,
what stops the next guy after one bombing in some part of the world to start it
up again?
Yeah.
Essentially we've been at war in some functions since the 1940s but
realistically when,
you know,
we were in the 90s at least we didn't feel like we were at war.
We didn't feel like it until 2001 they didn't invoke the extreme authority
either.
I mean,
it's a,
you know,
they didn't do that in Vietnam.
Even they didn't,
the government didn't say,
okay,
uh,
we're going to lock up every one of Vietnamese descent in a,
in a cage for awhile in case they're spies.
This is,
uh,
like when Truman did the Korean War thing and he got around having to declare
war by saying it's not a war,
it's a police action.
That was a marketing tool.
But by doing that,
he also essentially swore he didn't officially because kind of swore off that
and I'm going to have extreme constitutional authority.
He didn't take that up.
It's when Bush did this war on terror thing and basically the neo-con folks
said,
remember John,
you the advisor to the president,
the office of Legal Counsel said that if the president wanted to,
he could torture a son to get the father to talk.
There are no limits in war time.
No one had really invoked that since the Second World War.
So if you want to have total power,
just start war,
well,
that's an age old thing.
You can go back to the Romans and the Greeks and they were all in.
They understood that dynamic real well.
And so did the founding fathers of our country who were classically trained.
I mean,
the reason we're not a democracy in one respect is that they were fully aware of
how that could go and they were fully aware of what happened to Rome.
So if you look at the checks and balances in our constitution,
a lot of that stuff is to design,
to keep the same thing from happening to us.
I think they understood that those things break down over time though.
And that in essentially you might have a lifespan to what they were creating.
And that sense,
it's very fascinating,
the idea of a representative democracy and the,
the idea that there's an electoral college and the idea that there's,
there's a few steps beyond actual democracy.
It's like,
it's sort of,
you get a vote,
but you get to vote for a representative.
You don't get to completely vote like
one person,
one vote.
And,
uh,
the idea behind it initially was sorta to protect people from their own
silliness,
right?
Well,
they didn't,
the founding fathers didn't necessarily like the idea of average people running
the show.
If you looked at the state laws,
most states wouldn't let average joes vote.
I mean,
if you were working for a tinker in Virginia,
you probably weren't allowed to vote.
You used to have to be a landowner and most of these states,
and what that was designed to do was to limit the vote to stakeholders,
right?
They figured if you could run a farm without going out of business,
you probably knew enough about what was going on to be an educated voter.
Plus they didn't like the idea.
I mean,
you'll probably know this,
that after the revolution wasn't that long afterwards,
we had things like the whiskey rebellion and the Shay's rebellion.
These are new revolutions and their revolutions coming from the lower classes
and our brand new,
you know,
radical founding fathers shut those things down like nobody's business.
Yeah.
It's,
it's weird
when you think like that.
You think that the founding fathers didn't necessarily want everybody to vote
and be like,
wait,
wait a minute,
what?
But,
but the romantic version of it is that they were these beautiful people that had
this idea of treating people the way they deserve to be treated in govern with
respect and honesty and
well,
but also look at the times.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean when you realize that when they had the revolution,
we became the first major country in the world that had anything like that.
Then you start to realize,
okay,
we're looking back at our standards now and not realizing how radical those guys
were for their day.
And it's worth pointing out that only a few years after our revolution,
the French had theirs,
which got wickedly out of hand very quickly.
And our founding fathers were looking at what happened in France and the French
were saying that a lot of what they were doing was,
was was as,
as you know,
sort of a respecting kind of thing from what you know,
reflection of ours.
And they were going,
don't blame that on us.
We never would have gone that far.
We wouldn't kill noblemen we would.
So I think it was radical for the times.
It looks very conservative and a little little fascist.
Now when we look back on it,
the one thing that concerns me now,
I mean,
uh,
I think this country is,
we,
we sort of feel that we're immune to a revolution.
I don't think that anybody has any,
I think the average person,
I shouldn't say they don't think that anyone's going to overthrow the
government.
It's not really anything that anybody really believes or thinks of.
It's like,
Oh God,
you know,
the United States government is way too big for that.
But there's a lot of people in this country that don't think that there's a lot
of people in this country that are stockpiling guns.
And there's a lot of people in this country that think that the government's ban
on assault weapons and all these different magazine restrictions is just
designed to squash the,
the oppression or the rather resistance to their oppression.
And that when,
when the time comes,
you know,
they're not going to give up their guns because they know what's going to
happen.
That the government's going to come and get,
like,
I've never heard this before in my life,
this kind of thinking,
I don't remember it in high school.
I don't remember in college,
I don't remember.
But now I read about it on the Internet,
like on a fairly regular basis.
I read about people that are saying,
I've read,
um,
uh,
there was,
what,
what it was the task force where a police chief was developing a task force to
protect them in case they're a invaded by the United States government.
Oh,
that was in Texas.
In Texas.
One of those wacky places.
I thought it was Oklahoma,
but it was one of those places where you're like,
Whoa,
settle down.
But,
but hold on,
keep talking.
What the fuck are you thinking?
Like what do you,
what do you think is going on?
You think the is going to come and take all the guns and they're,
they're ready to put together a task force to like band together to protect the
citizens and their guns from the oppressive government.
I've never heard talk like that from an elected official in recent memory.
You got two different things going on here and they're both really important.
The first one was when you talked about the revolution thing,
I'm of a different mind.
I try to look at what's the likelihood of a staying the way we are.
I'm not sure.
I mean,
could could a revolution happened?
Sure,
but could we go the other way too where there's just a cracking down on things
to an even more extent.
In other words,
the government gets overthrown on one side of the spectrum.
The government cracks down and says,
okay,
all this constitutional stuff we've,
we've paid attention to.
We can't do that.
You know,
if two more buildings fall down,
I think all,
you know,
ever been just going to throw everything out the window.
I mean look at how far we've come since the nine 11 attacks.
Now magnify that.
If it happened again from where we are now.
So I think the real question is can we really see things staying in this middle
ground where we are for another 10 or 20 or 30 years?
I could see it going to either extreme.
It's hard for me to imagine us actually staying in this sort of status that
we're in right now.
They certainly think we're in a period of change.
Um,
what I wonder is,
is it possible that people could be organized enough to do it and,
and,
and get something going on without violence?
I mean is,
is it possible to,
is it possible to overhaul government from an elected official point of view?
Can you just elect the right people and slowly but surely they'd take care of
things.
I mean,
is it,
is it even possible at this point?
Well,
I want to address your other point cause I think that was very good to the idea
of this whole,
um,
you know,
we need the guns to stop the government from,
from taking over or whatever.
I first encountered this when I was on the radio in Oregon because once you get
out into the back country,
where are you getting?
And this was in the era of the so called militia movement and everything and you
get these people calling you talking about that exact thing.
You know,
what happened in malicious,
I think the mainstream,
I think they're still out there.
I think they're just,
they're the people in the government and the guy who you mentioned in Texas,
probably an old militia member,
but these guys,
and this is something that the um,
the nras kind of pushed to the areas of very different animal than it was 30 or
40 years ago.
And one of the things they talk about now that they didn't use to talk about was
this idea that part of the reasons we have a second amendment is to overthrow
the government.
If you need to,
um,
I'll leave that to a constitutional expert.
I would just point out that,
that I think people who think like that are,
are,
are not paying a whole lot of attention to how much things have changed
militarily.
You and I were talking about drones a minute ago,
who thinks any government person's going to put themselves out as a target?
They're just going to send a drone to your house.
And you know,
I mean I think,
I think that ship has sailed but there's a lot of people,
you remember there was Randy Weaver up in Idaho that got um,
you know,
into this conflict with federal agents cause he's at the Ruby Ridge as he saw
it,
a shotgun off a little too far in a government agent,
bought it from him and then all of a sudden their surrounding his cabin and
shooting his dog and shooting his wife and killing his son,
which really was a kind of a bad deal.
I mean it was,
it was,
he had a case,
this is what I guess I'm saying,
but he was a bad enough,
weird enough unibomber looking kind of dude that you could spin that into.
Well he's a radical gun nuts kind of thing.
And then you have the Waco situation happened.
Same thing.
A bunch of really weird dudes.
So you want to kind of go,
well,
I mean,
look at who you're dealing with,
child abuse and this or that.
But you kind of lose how nasty a deal that was because it's like terrorist.
You can do anything you want to terrorist.
And if it's to terrorists,
we don't care as much.
Um,
I think when you talk about,
um,
changing the elected officials and all that,
we talk about this all the time.
I mean,
let's,
let's call it as it really is.
We have a corrupt government.
Um,
when you have a representative,
undeniably,
and they'll tell you that if you catch him off record,
they know.
And when you have a government that's a representative democracy,
like we have,
you have a government by middlemen,
right?
We have a membrane.
If Joe Rogan gets a bunch of people together to change the laws,
you have to go through these representatives.
If that membrane is corrupt,
no matter what you do,
when you end up with legislation on the other side of that membrane,
it's going to have been tainted on the way through.
And this is why when you talk about reform,
reform has to get through those people.
They're the ones benefiting from the way things are,
right?
So in other words,
if you say,
let's have some anticorruption legislation,
who is going to be the people most hurt by that?
The people that benefit from the way things are.
So this is sort of the fly in the ointment.
How do you get corruption reform through the very people that are benefiting
from corruption?
So that's the problem.
And what is the answer?
Well,
this is another question entirely.
I think this is when you pressure people,
I think when you talk about,
let me think about the sixties protests.
People today make a big deal.
If you can get 50,000 people out with signs for one afternoon,
that's a huge protest in the world of the 21st century.
You've got to think of sixties protests when you have two hundred and fifty
thousand three hundred thousand four hundred thousand civil rights type protests
that are putting real pressure on the government.
I think that's what it's gonna take.
It's gonna take a real feeling like,
okay,
the Jig is up.
Um,
this whole,
you know,
we're in threatened,
we're threatened with revolution.
You talked about revolution were threatened with revolution.
If we don't buckle down and you're going to have to have those people that are
really feel like,
okay,
we have no choice.
I don't care what my contributor gave me to push this idea.
We're going to have to at least throw something out there that's a fig leaf.
And they don't feel that pressure.
Now is it possible,
and this was my,
my question,
is it possible to go and get new elected officials and change that?
I mean,
can you get people that aren't willing to be corrupt and aren't willing to
capitalize on the system as it's written right now and profit off of it?
And
yeah,
that scene from the Kevin Costner version of the untouchables,
there's a scene in that movie,
and I quote it all the time where Al Capone has bought off the jury and he's
sitting in court and he knows he has nothing to worry about cause he's paid off
the whole jury.
And they've realized that he's paid off the jury.
So at the last minute,
right before the verdict is read,
the judge dismisses all the jury members and brings in all the alternates and
screws up the whole thing because now all of a sudden,
instead of a corrupt jury,
you have one that hasn't been bought off.
The way our government is set up is designed to keep radical change from
happening.
It doesn't turn over all at once and there's a seniority system so that,
let's say you elected a third of the congress is new people not corrupt.
They're part of an,
you know,
you have the tea party thing.
Now imagine instead of the tea party,
you had an anticorruption movement that was able to bring in a whole bunch of
new congresspeople and their whole shtick is that we're non-corrupt,
we're not going to vote for any of this corruption.
The first thing that's going to happen is they're going to be told to sit in the
back of the room and shut up till they have seniority.
When you're here,
two or three terms,
we'll maybe give you a committee position.
If you show that you're going to play ball,
we'll let you run the committee.
I mean there's this whole system where you don't get to be influential until
you've proven you're a good corrupt official for a long time and you're not
allowed to overthrow the entire government at once.
You have to go in there and then you're still going to have John Kerry and John
Mccain and all those guys running the show while you're in the back.
If you're lucky,
getting a chance to give a speech on Cspan in front of an empty congression a
room because all of your compatriots are out fundraising.
Do you know that they have phone banks right off the congressional property
cause you're not allowed to fundraise on government property.
So they've built these phone banks like one foot off government property and
they go in there and they cast their vote and then their aids take them right to
the phone banks and they start the fundraising.
80% of their time is spent fundraising and they don't want to do this.
I should say that some of these guys,
um,
you know,
Peter De Fazio is a congressman from Oregon.
He didn't run for Senate because he said I'm already fundraising more than my
conscience will allow and if I become a senator I have to do even more of that.
So there are some good people in there.
They're just,
I think outnumbered,
you know,
85% to 15 or something like that.
So their fund raising is essentially just person to person phone calls.
Oh yeah.
And as a matter of fact they will tell you when and you know,
you can almost see how they've compromised their own moral sense when you have a
conversation with some of these guys.
Cause like one of them told me,
he said,
listen,
this is democracy in action and it's okay because anybody can play this game.
He said if you have money,
and I said what about poor people?
It's the poor people could get together in large organizations and groups.
He said if you have money you get to play.
He said it's totally fair.
It's a totally level playing field.
Anybody can take part,
but money is how you get our attention and they've convinced themselves that
this is fine.
To be honest,
it's been going on in one form or another for so long and some of these guys
have been on the hill for 30 years.
I mean to them,
this is just how it works.
Um,
Lawrence Lessig um,
wrote a book where he,
he talked to some of these guys and they're almost confused.
He had one guy where he went in and,
and,
and the guy was voting on one side of an issue and Lawrence Lessig said,
well,
what about this other side of the issue?
And the guy was completely unaware that anybody disagreed with the issue at all
because he hadn't heard from the other side because the other side hadn't given
any money.
He was unaware there was another side.
Wow.
You know,
so,
so in a sense,
I mean I'm not trying to let these guys off the hook,
but they're in this bubble.
I mean,
I remember we had a,
I'll even name a name here.
I had senator Mark Hatfield on my radio show once,
and this is way back in the 1990s and he comes on the show and he's about 80
years old and he's led by the hand by some 19 year old girl who's his aide,
who's talking to him like he's an Alzheimer's patient.
Okay,
Senator Hatfield's,
you're going to sit down and you're going to talk to this guy for 15 minutes.
Exactly.
Then we have to go to the car.
And I mean,
he was like an uh,
he was like a robot.
I mean,
he was,
okay,
I'll talk to this guy and then where are we going next?
And I mean,
I thought the guy was like,
you know,
a Manchurian candidate.
They just hopped up on some kind of,
they'd given him an injection and then they just lead him to wherever he has to
go.
But in a sense,
I felt sorry for the guy because to go in and say,
what are you doing about corruption?
The first thing he's going to do is turn to his aid and goes,
do we have a corruption problem?
It was just on my schedule.
I mean he really did know.
So I don't want to cast these people as evil.
I'm not sure how much they're aware of some of this stuff.
We'll also,
the businesses existed in this certain form,
the form that it's in right now for quite a long time.
So this is nothing new.
It's,
it's an evolution.
So when they come into this Gig,
everybody who works the Gig,
I mean,
as they're,
they're learning the business and learning how it works.
It's just this is how it is.
Oh Man.
You go to orientation,
if you get elected of Joe Rogan gets elected to Congress your first week on the
hill,
you go to orientation and they're going to tell you where the cafeteria is.
They're going to tell you,
you know,
where the phone banks are and this and that.
And the other thing,
I mean,
you get essentially trained how to be an elected official and then they sit you
in the back and you get to watch how business is done for a term or two.
You know?
And that's how,
I mean,
look at,
look at Ron Wyden.
He's another Oregon senator.
He's the one making the big stink about not being able to get any of these
secret documents on the drones and everything else.
Widen is on the Senate intelligence committee,
which I believe is eight senators and you'd have to be there like forever to get
on the intelligence committee.
And the committee is supposed to be the ones who actually get the secret stuff.
Believe it or not,
we don't tell senators the secret stuff.
We only tell the people on the intelligence committee,
the secret stuff about intelligence and widened says the eight guys on that
can't get the information.
So you have to be a senator for years and years and years to be trusted enough
to be on the intelligence committee.
So when you say,
couldn't we get new people in here and couldn't that fix everything?
No new person's going to even be given the secret intelligence until they prove
that they will play ball for many terms.
And then you don't get to be the head of the intelligence committee until you
prove that even more.
So.
It's essentially if you looked at the government as a living organism,
it's like it's trying to protect itself.
It has an immunity system.
It's,
Yep,
it every bureaucracy is like that.
Most companies when they get large enough or even like that.
Now tell me about these phone banks.
So they,
they,
they get off the floor and they go one foot pass the government at the property
and they just call who,
who are these people?
How do they get their numbers right?
Well,
generally what happens is they have a staff and they're going to have somebody
on their staff who helps them raise money and there's going to be fundraising
targets.
Lessig talks about this in his book.
They will say,
you need to raise this much per day and if you fall short the next day it just,
it rolls over.
You have to make that much more per day and they'll have targeting goals that
are designed to be met by the next time you have to start campaigning.
Now is that money to support their next campaign?
That is that money what it is?
That's
the best question of all because this is the one empowering thing about the
whole deal that goes right back to us as voters and how we can actually change
things.
This money is mostly,
some of it's for campaign organization,
right?
You want your guys going door to door,
you want to have,
you want to have your campaign office opened up in Iowa if you're running for
president right away,
you know,
those kind of things.
So there's some money that goes to that,
but the majority of this money is designed for ads.
Right?
And what are the ads designed to do to change your mind?
What if the ads didn't work anymore?
You know,
why all of a sudden,
you know,
we already are from a generation that's a lot more cynical about advertising
anyway.
And you and I are both in a business where we realize how much of a tougher time
advertisers have than they used to have.
And the old days,
I mean,
all you have to do is,
you know,
we have a new,
uh,
surreal and it's got some different colored marshmallows and boom.
I mean they're selling that like hotcakes now.
It's,
it's a much more cynical group.
We have the dvrs and all these things that allow you to skip ads.
What if they stopped working?
What if the old people who still buy into advertising the old way it happens.
That generation goes away and now all of a sudden everybody's like us.
Don't you devalue what that money buys?
Haven't we changed the system simply by not paying attention to the ads that the
entire system,
the money is designed to change your mind.
If it doesn't change your mind anymore,
it doesn't.
The whole thing kind of collapsed.
I mean,
I don't know cause we haven't seen it happen,
but that seems to be the whole fly in the ointment when it comes to campaign and
money raising and everything else.
If I can't change your mind with the money,
why do I want to sell my soul and spend 80% of my time fundraising?
The whole point is to change your mind.
Well,
the one thing that always changes my mind is those negative ads,
like the really obvious one,
you know,
President Obama Odor,
like when they get like real,
super negative,
you just can't trust him.
Why those work though?
They work because you don't have an alternative.
I mean it,
that's the whole democratic and republican thing.
If you had five choices and one guy went negative against another guy,
the average voter to say,
well,
I'm not voting for either.
I've heard bad things about both those guys.
So I'm voting for this third party.
The two party thing gets you into the lesser of two evils,
or your waste,
your vote nonsense.
And that's where,
I mean,
that's why the negative ads work.
Like they do that.
That's something that would go away if you had multiple choices.
You can't do five negative ads very easily.
Well,
it became much more difficult for independence after Ron,
not Ron Paul,
excuse me.
After um,
Perot.
Ross Perot.
Yeah.
When Ross Perot came around and paid for his own television half hour to uh,
you know,
talk about his campaign and taxes and where your money's going and the Federal
Reserve.
A lot of people have never heard any of that stuff before.
What if a not so goofy character had done it too?
I mean,
what if you'd had somebody who would,
if Robert Redford,
you know,
he gets right,
I had a political science professor,
yeah.
From,
he was from Germany,
real old guy when I was in college and he said that one of the flaws in the
American system was that they have the PR,
the job of president is actually two jobs in most foreign countries.
Usually you'll have like a prime minister and a guy who's called the chancellor
or the president,
the prime ministers,
the bean counter guy,
the guy who's really,
you know,
you put in there to do the work and then the chancellor or the president is the
figurehead guy,
the guy who goes to the state funerals,
the one who embodies the soul of the nation.
And this guy said in your country,
those two things have to be in the same person.
So when you elect to Ronald Reagan,
what you were electing is a John Wayne.
You want that guy.
I mean who,
who do you think of as president?
You don't want some wimpy bean counter account and looking guy.
You want some guy that looks like America,
right?
But how often do you get the skills you want in the bean counter?
I say bean counter,
but you know it's a,
it's a whole range of things.
But how often are you going to combine the Robert Redford look of a person with
the guy who's going to have all those other qualities you want,
especially if they've been an eraser,
clapper politician for 30 years or something.
So we're kind of hamstrung by that.
So if Ross,
can you imagine Ross Perot is president?
Because I think most people are like,
yeah,
I like what he's saying,
but I can't imagine that little short,
strange talking.
We're going to clean out the barn kind of guy being president.
I think I would have imagined he could have pulled it off.
I think so.
I wish you know,
I mean,
yeah,
and you know what,
to be honest,
I don't know what kind of president he'd be at.
My standards are just so low now.
I mean,
if they're honest,
I'm on board mean forget about it.
And are there specific policies my,
my take on it would be completely,
I mean it really would be all just guesswork because I have no idea what the
hell happens when you actually get into office,
I guess.
But I really have no idea what the whole process must be like to say,
when I'm president,
I'm going to do this.
And when you actually get elected and then you have meetings and get access and
get debriefed and they explain the world to you in a way that really no one has
access to other than the president.
Sure.
You're not bypassing that moment at the inauguration where they hit you up with
the needle and turn you into an imaginary candidate and me go,
go read a book.
You go look at Obama's speeches.
I tell everybody to go do this.
Go Watch candidate Obama's speeches when he's running for the first term in
office and compare
that to what we've had and then realize that that's pretty darn normal.
The before and after thing,
you do start to come to this conspiratorial idea that some,
you know,
they go to Europe,
they go to you right before your Noggin,
racially,
we're going to kill your whole family if you don't do just what,
you know what every other president does.
Do you ever heard of the Bill Hicks bit about it?
No.
Tell me about the buildings up and his take was,
he goes,
uh,
I think that when you get become president,
they take you into a smoky room filled with industrialists and it goes,
all right,
roll the tape.
And he goes,
and then a projector drops down and they show you an angle of the Kennedy
assassination.
It's never been seen before.
Perfect.
And they say any questions?
That's right.
Exactly.
It's like,
yeah,
Joe,
what's my agenda?
Well,
I mean it's almost like an Algebra problem when you try to
plain all the reasons that these people might morph so much after election day.
Yeah,
they'll start to start looking not that far fetched because it's hard to explain
otherwise unless,
unless these people just think campaign promises or campaign promises and that's
all.
And I and I,
and I've been,
I mean look Obama was,
was the favorite of guys like Goldman Sachs and Citibank when he was running for
office.
It's hard to square his agenda while running that he talked to the people with
the people that were providing the money.
And so I think,
I think maybe that has more to do with it than anything else.
I mean we're not getting grassroots.
You don't have Abbie Hoffman running for president,
you know?
And if he was in Goldman Sachs were backing him,
I have a feeling he'd do the same thing.
Yeah.
His with the image that was being portrayed was like nothing we'd ever seen
before.
It was like,
oh okay.
He actually is us.
He is the misfit.
He is America.
He is half black,
half white.
He is a raised by a single mom.
He is,
you know,
not from a silver spoon background.
He's a persons cannot understand the
constitutional law scholar.
Remember all those to see,
this is where the Obama administration really angers me.
It's not unusual to have some president go off half cocked and do wild,
crazy things like President Bush did after nine 11 in fact,
I'm,
I'm kind of for,
I kind of forgive those people a little bit because I think it's unrealistic to
expect us to have acted sane after nine 11 as a matter of fact,
I've often said if we were smart people,
we would put legislation in right now mandating a cooling off period after the
next nine 11 so we don't legislate while we're temporarily insane.
I think the fact we don't do that shows you that they'd like to legislate when
we're temporarily insane,
but I think we were going to go crazy when that happened.
It's the responsibility of the next guy though to get us back on track because
if he doesn't,
what was an anomaly becomes the new law of the land when Obama from the other
party running on a platform that he's going to fix the abuses of the previous
administration instead codifies them.
That's the new reality.
Now that's not an anomaly.
That's not an administration before him.
That was just different.
This is new post nine
11 world with both parties on board.
How much say do you believe he has and the day to day things?
I mean,
how much say does he have in our foreign policy where we go,
what we do?
Well,
it's interesting because this gets back to a point we made earlier.
Um,
more than normal because of that whole war time authority that we talked about
earlier.
First of all,
presidents have more authority in the realm of foreign policy anyway.
That's always been considered.
The reason presidents like to dabble in foreign policies cause they have the
most leeway there.
If they want to get into budgetary things domestically,
you start running into congressional roadblocks all the time.
So presidents,
even when they're not foreign policy guys liked to do foreign policy stuff cause
you can actually do stuff and the congress can't say much about it in war time.
This guy has got amazing authority.
I mean imagine using those same rationales that they use anytime they want to do
something with the war on terror but using them for something totally.
Okay,
we're going to stop this budget impasse because we're in a war on terror and I
have supreme authority and I'm just going to do what I want to do.
What would anybody say?
Nobody's talked about limiting extreme more time authority at all.
I mean,
if the Republicans are going to say,
well you know,
you can't do that in war time.
Well Gosh,
it's nice.
There's a line,
somebody,
somebody who's designated to limit to the powers,
they don't do that.
Now there's a book by um,
a Yale constitutional law professor named Bruce Ackerman,
I think it's called the fall of the American republic.
And it's a little too wonky for most people,
but what he's essentially done is target what he thinks is the fly in the
ointment.
In terms of of these laws,
and it's the presidential office of legal counsel.
It's essentially the president's lawyers.
These were supposed to be people who could answer the president's question,
is this constitutional?
Is it not constitutional?
Instead,
it's become the kind of people who explained to the president how we can do
something.
That's who John you was.
He was one of these people with president would say,
um,
how do we do this and how do we justify it constitutionally?
And it was John used job to go find out how to do that,
right?
Every president has these guys and what what Ackerman was saying is by the time
the supreme court gets around to ruling on these things,
it's often two,
three terms.
After that was first,
and it's been the law of the land for a long time.
Now imagine the Supreme Court ruling on something from 1994 and saying,
everything we've done since 94 is wrong.
You have to overturn it all.
That doesn't tend to happen.
And so the office of legal counsel can make these rulings and there the law of
the land until they're challenged and overturned by a court.
By the time the court sees that it's settled law,
it seems to me we're in like a system that is,
it's like compared to the other day to an old car,
it's like you can have a model t and keep changing the oil and keep fixing.
Things are in place in the parts and it kind of keep working.
It's gonna require a lot of work,
but it will sort of get you where you go.
Got to go.
Or You could buy a brand new Cadillac and you're not going to have any fucking
problems at all.
You know why?
Because it's improved.
It's been redesigned.
They've got all the kinks out,
fixed the flaws and designed a completely new thing.
We don't have that in government.
We have like this old patchwork government.
We have this old Wah,
Wah,
Wacky I imperfect sort of system.
What am I?
Listeners brought up a point that that that I,
that I thought of before,
but I'd forgotten.
And when you think about it,
it's rather,
um,
it's,
it's a good point.
He said,
not just that,
it's a government designed for a tiny country,
you know,
a one on one with 13 colonies all on the east coast,
relatively homogenous and the whole thing.
And you're expecting that same system to work now.
You know,
you had 13 million people then or something.
You have 300 million now with airplanes.
Totally.
Any Internet and globalization where we're dealing with all these other
countries in ways.
I mean,
we used to have two really nice protective barriers,
the Atlantic and Pacific oceans that are not barriers at all now.
So yeah,
so things,
I mean,
that sense you're expecting a system designed in a completely different set of
circumstances to adapt.
Now,
Thomas Jefferson said that that's why the constitution was built to be amended.
He said to expect a child to adjacent,
to expect this constitution to work as we wrote it forever,
would be to expect a child to continue to wear the same suit of clothes as they
grow up.
But there's a limit,
right?
I mean at a certain point you reach the stretching point maybe.
And again if the legislators and all those people were really acting in our
interests,
maybe they could make it work.
But when you have them working at cross purposes from us on a lot of this stuff
that's asking too much.
That's systemic failure.
Yeah,
and when you,
you,
you get situations like corporations having the ability to spend as much money
as they like on candidates where you,
you have no restriction in how much money they can spend to influence someone
who gets into office.
It's so transparent.
It's like how does that ever get to be the way we run things?
Cause it seems like that's the most obvious method of bribery ever.
Well there's another one because even if you got rid of that,
how do you stop this revolving door that we see where they say,
listen man,
don't worry about it when you get out of office.
We got a nice cushy job at this defense industry or whatever where you helped us
out.
We'll help you on the other side.
You'll be a very rich person.
We see that all the time.
How do you stop that?
Did you hear about the guy who was the head of Monsanto's now the head of the
FDA?
Well,
it's like,
oh,
Bama.
Just put another guy in the treasury department that works for like city group
or something and you turn around and go,
it bothers me less than he did it.
Then he doesn't mind that we saw he did it in and everything that's gone on.
I mean you don't even,
that's when the gloves are off.
We used to hide the corruption.
Now it's so open.
Nobody even cares and that that's when you've reached a tipping point,
I think.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
The open.
That's just hoping that there's so much going on all we just have to suck it up
as people.
We have nothing we could do.
What do you,
what are you going to do?
Vote for Mitt Romney.
I mean,
that's how it goes.
Yeah.
Well that was hilarious.
It's like,
what do you,
you want to call
it member or you want the same?
I mean they,
they came up with one of the weirdest candidates ever.
A comp,
a cult member,
billionaire with obvious disdain for the lower class and the working class.
And what do you know what,
when was the last time though?
I think that's almost a,
but you want to talk about conspiracy theories that,
that Oliver Stone can do a movie about.
How about how we end up with these kinds of elections were how often is it one
guy that you'd like to replace and another guy who's worse?
Yeah,
I mean you look at Bill Clinton,
Bob Doll,
you look at,
I remember people forget this,
we've lionized and romanticized Reagan so much.
People forget that an 84 there's a lot of people that would have gotten rid of
Reagan.
You remember who he ran against though?
Walter Mondale.
Talk about people.
You can imagine president.
I mean this happens all the time.
How about Nick Nixon?
Humphrey,
I mean,
my God,
you look at these,
these are not this,
this is like saying let's have a good game of a,
a paper view NFL and we'll put the patriots up against some college team.
You know,
I mean it's not even competitive.
Yeah.
Maybe a high school team there.
You got the Mitt Romney's.
Yeah.
Um,
it is funny if you want to go crazy,
Alex Jones conspiratorial,
he sort of a design a roadmap.
How they've decided,
decided to keep certain presidents.
They believe that that's one of the,
that was one of the problems with Ross Perot.
I said Ross Perot is how Bill Clinton got into office three way split.
Yeah.
Because Ross Perot took away from George Herbert Walker.
Maybe.
Maybe I can see that.
Sure.
But I remember a lot of people at the time,
uh,
thinking like,
wow,
uh,
what are they going to do about this?
Like he,
this guy did the commission on presidential debates up the bar.
I always try to tell people,
do you realize that the debates used to be run by the League of women voters?
They got out of the Gig.
And the late eighties,
because the,
the rules that the Democrats and Republicans wanted in terms of controlling the
debate and the questions and everything else.
They said,
well we won't run a debate under those conditions.
And they expected the other side to back down.
And the other side,
which were the two parties instead said,
great,
we didn't want to deal with you guys anyway,
we'll form our own commission,
will make up for members on it,
will be Democrats for will be Republicans and we'll set the standard for where
non Democrats or Republicans can play a role.
Um,
Perot exceeded their original rules and he was able to get enough of the
population and involvement in rise enough in the polls because of his money.
Like you said,
to get in the debates.
Nobody wanted him in the debates.
Nobody likes,
I mean they sweated.
You remember it cause he brings up things that are bipartisan failures.
And this is the rule of the debates don't bring up.
If the Democrats can't tell the Republicans,
you know,
or the Republicans can't tell the Democrats or blame them for something that
they had nothing to do with.
We don't talk about it.
The debt,
for example,
that was bit Perot's big issue.
That's a bipartisan creation.
So the two parties had no reason to bring that up.
You throw the third guy in there though.
Oh,
he's going to make everybody sweat because nobody has a good answer for
bipartisan failures.
So after parole crash,
the debates,
the commission on presidential debates upped the rules for
inclusion and I went back and did the history of it.
Do you realize that there's never been a candidate in American politics from any
third party or independent that's ever come anywhere near their current bar that
they've said?
I mean,
Teddy Roosevelt ran as a third party candidate from the Bull Moose party after
he'd already been president.
Right?
A very popular president running against two people that nobody wanted.
He wouldn't have reached the benchmark to be included in the modern presidential
third.
You know,
you're never going to have a third party person,
and again,
it's 15% they raised it to write more than that.
You have to raise a certain amount of money.
You have to reach certain polls,
standards in a number of different polls,
and you have to,
there's a name recognition thing.
I mean,
it's a whole list of criteria in that hilarious name recognition.
Yes.
Before the debates is where you get the name recognition.
That's right.
Really quite cute.
Yeah.
I'm Gary Johnson.
Never had a chance.
Oh,
among other people.
I mean,
you know,
there's,
listen,
you're going to have to get a very rich,
handsome,
famous person to run and they're going to still have to have all the breaks go
their way.
They're gonna have to be running against Walter Mondale and Bob Dole.
So essentially they've legally slapped it down to a two party system.
There really is no third parties.
What I like about it is I liked how they both act as though it's in the
constitution somewhere.
While we have a two party system.
No,
we don't.
Where'd you find that?
That's a,
that's a little propaganda from the two party.
We don't have in any party system.
The founders hated party,
they called him factions and they hated it.
And it was like a generation later.
There we are.
Well,
when you have an issue like Bush to Obama where you not only do you see very
little change and how we operate same foreign policy almost exactly.
Almost.
Exactly.
But what is it then?
What are you,
where's the change?
Where's the change and where's the hope?
And if there's only two parties and you're both being funded by the same
gigantic corporations and banks,
whoa.
Like what really has happened here?
The late Gore Vidal said we have one party in this country with two wings that
represents 4% of the population.
I mean that might be,
it might be a little extreme,
but,
but you start to see that way.
I mean,
especially when you compare what we consider to be left and right to say Europe
for example.
I mean,
first of all,
our Republicans are to the right of anything.
You know,
almost there's a few fascist parties in real weirdos in Europe.
But we're to the right of anything like that and our Democrats are to the right
of most of their parties too.
Well,
you know,
I have this conversation with a good buddy of mine,
Brian Callen all the time when we talk about how crazy the world is today,
but yet the greatest time to live ever.
The safest time to live ever.
The most prosperous time,
the most.
We're most technologically advanced time.
When you look at today in comparison to a thousand years ago,
how brutal life was,
or Geez,
even a few hundred.
Yeah.
Where would you want to go back to?
The dentistry alone would keep you in the modern day.
Yeah,
I mean we,
we have just this amazing potential as we stand today with our technological
abilities,
our internet connections are ability to exchange information.
We
see hobbled only by our representation.
It really does seem to be,
if you look at how advanced medicine is today,
if you look at how advanced sciences,
the incredible innovations that are coming out every day,
the one place where we're disappointing is in our representation.
You know,
courage to me as you say that,
you know,
maybe,
maybe you and I and,
and the people who think like us are weird sort of minority.
Maybe you could,
you could come up with this idea and like I'm fleshing this out as we talk,
but I mean maybe there's a way to look at this outside our comfort zone where
people might say,
you know,
if all you do is play video games every day you go to Uta,
who cares?
Maybe they would say,
well listen,
I mean,
why do I care about the fact that the government's corrupt and why do I care
that all of these things are going on?
And why do I care about drones?
What does it matter to me?
I have the best life anybody's ever had in all history.
What am I missing?
And I think that's where you get into these arguments that we make about
slippery slopes.
Well,
hey man,
just cause you're happy today.
You know,
wait until a video game players who download games without permission or struck
by drones.
I mean,
so,
so I guess maybe there's a way to look at it that there might be a lot of
people.
It's like,
you know,
brave new world territory that don't care.
There was certainly are,
I have my medical marijuana,
I have my video games.
I,
uh,
you know,
I have my days off,
I'm on my disability payments and who cares?
That's I think what infuriates people about the whole hipster attitude.
That's what infuriates people about the attitude.
Like,
whatever,
who cares?
I'm not,
you know,
I'm here for me.
I don't care about what's going on.
Whatever.
Am I going to fix China?
Am I going to Afghanistan?
Uh,
my own problems were with,
I wasn't born into a society of the day I created myself.
It already existed.
I'll just move forward.
But I think as human beings,
we all ultimately realized that we're in this together and that a lot of people
had to exist before us that had the better good of mankind in mind when they
developed computer chips,
when they develop TVs,
when they develop cars,
we didn't develop anything.
We just sort of stumbled on.
It's our job to do the same thing,
to continue innovating as those before us have innovated in every way.
Whether it's socially,
technologically,
or governmentally.
We,
we,
we haven't governmentally it's The r one area where we've really stalled.
We really have in fact slipped backwards and to a,
a goofy your system cause it's more transparent.
People are more upset than ever and still government operates the same way.
When we saw the bailouts,
and I remember there was a speech where Obama gave where he said he was limiting
the bonuses of the CEOs to like,
I was like a half a million dollars and a,
I was like,
this is the craziest,
you're watching robbery take place right before your eyes.
And this guy who's the representative of the people,
this Obama character is letting you know they're only going to rob a half a
million dollars each.
Like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
their company failed.
But see they have a contract and even though the bank didn't they all their
money,
that guy gets money.
Money is money.
Money is I think what,
what when we just,
you know,
my little fly in the ointment of this idea I had,
I think the fact that it's going to be very hard for a lot of Americans to make
a decent living is the most likely thing to prompt change.
I remember in the 1990s and I was doing my radio show,
I was the worst radio show host in the world for for the times cause like I was
on the station that had like these conservative stereotypical radio hosts all
day long.
And then right in the middle of the day part it was me and I didn't fit any of
these things.
So I fought with the audience all day long because they were these hold overs
from the other conservative shows.
And so I'm screaming and yelling about,
you know,
when are you going to get out of the streets?
When are you going to do something?
Some guy called me up and said something very prophetic.
I thought about it many times.
He goes,
people aren't going to go out and face the bay and nets while they're able to
pay their bills and they have the food they want and they can give their kids a
halfway decent life.
He said when that changes,
everything else will too,
and you sit there and think about what,
what's happened to middle class jobs in this country.
The so called middle class jobs,
it's a combination of changes in trade deals,
which we all know about,
but also automation,
which has gotten rid of a lot of jobs that the Av,
I always talk about them as the average joes and Janes,
people that don't have really high expectations but they want to work.
They'll go to work and they raise a family and maybe save up for college and you
just make it work.
A little shell game here and there,
but just a decent life.
That's the American dream,
right?
You take that away and maybe,
I mean when those video game,
medicinal marijuana smoking hipster people can't pay the bills and get evicted.
Maybe that's the kind of wakeup call that changes their belief system.
And maybe that's where you say we live in the greatest time ever.
Yeah.
Unless you're a black person in prison because they caught you with a little
cocaine or maybe less.
You're some guy that just got evicted and your house is under water.
I mean those are the things that all of a sudden make you and when you have
enough of those people,
because nobody cares if it's 1% of the population,
if 40% of the population dropped from what was the middle class into the lower
class,
I think agitation hits an a level that you and I in our lifetimes haven't seen.
Well,
I think it's at a level now.
I think it's on the way.
Yeah.
Where we've never seen before.
And that's one of the things that I was alluding to when,
where it's what I was talking earlier about the desire to understand history.
I think that more people today,
and at least the conversations that I'm having based on my own personal
experiences,
more people are concerned with talking about the corruptions of the past.
And why shouldn't we be surprised or why should we be surprised?
There's so much fucked up shit going on in politics today.
Like,
did you know this?
Did you know that?
Like it's like,
I think there's a lot of people that are trying to figure out how the hell we
got,
so
that's,
you know what I was gonna you just took the words out of my mouth.
The reason history is important because it tells you how we got here.
Yeah.
My,
I had a teacher wants to said,
look you,
you joined a soap opera and you watch the soap opera and you're going,
who the hell is that?
Why?
Why are they mad at her and what?
Who screwed who?
I mean,
that's what history teaches you.
It gives you context.
You can understand the now.
No,
I think are the founding obviously
had some awesome ideas and then we're brilliant men and they were very well
schooled,
but you can't possibly ask people from 1776 to figure out a way that's going to
you.
You're going to govern people that exist in a time.
You could even possibly imagine the first people to say,
absolutely,
absolutely.
Come on,
man.
I gave it to you to take care of where are the whys high day,
where autopilot,
where are the wise men of today that step forth and and and and make sense of
the situation without need for you,
with or without greed,
without corruption,
where,
where are,
where are they?
Let me piggyback on that because I've thought about that to look at the 1960s
which ha whatever you may have thought about.
It was a period of change in whatever direction.
Look at how many people you can still name if you have any knowledge at all that
were leading their own segments of movements one way or the other.
They had tons of people.
Whether you want to talk about civil rights in the Martin Luther kings and the
Malcolm x is whether you want to talk about the yippies and all that.
What do you want to talk about?
Everything had these people that step forward that are on your Wikipedia page.
If you want to go look up,
who the hell does that today?
Can you name two people who are out front as political,
you know,
outside,
outside politics,
but people who lead movements and I can't,
they've done an awesome job of marginalizing those people.
The government's way better at preventing a Martin Luther King today.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
today you have your obvious race baiters like Jesse Jackson and you know,
you have,
that goes back.
I mean,
is he still around?
And I mean,
that's when I was in college.
I mean,
yeah,
constantly and constantly getting called out for what he's doing with
corporations and forcing them to pay enormous sums of money.
And he goes in for a racial education,
teaches people whenever they say,
I mean,
essentially what he does is he finds someone who's done something,
either that could be racially distasteful or said something that's out of line,
even in a joke.
And they go in and they blackmail him.
But that's not a leader.
That's just somebody who found their own little scam.
Who else?
Al Sharpton.
Even worse guy.
He started his whole career off with a fake rape case.
You know that Tijuana Brawley.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's your,
uh,
that's what they allow.
They allow the most preposterous to exist.
But again,
those don't represent any of those kinds of people from the 60s who legitimately
believed.
Um,
and that's what's missing.
And maybe you think it's because we're cynical or it's our generation.
I mean,
look,
you and I are about the same age we come.
Remember we were generation axe,
you're a bunch of slackers.
And everybody was like,
you know,
oh,
look of what this generation is going to be.
And the funny thing is,
I think compared to generations after us,
we look good.
So what does that mean?
If we're the slacker generation,
the people that came after us,
or even more than,
I mean,
are we reaping what we saw or oh,
I'm not so happy with what the baby boomers did.
So who knows how that,
you know,
I think that this generation that's growing up today have this insane advantage
of the Internet from birth.
Yes.
They do.
Imagine what those sixties people would have done with the Internet.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
w one of the things about the sixties it's such a Trevon for so hard for people
to wrap their head around it was that it was only 20 years after Hitler.
And that's,
that's a,
when you put that in your head,
I mean 20 years ago was what,
nineties I do this all the time.
It's funny you say that.
I remember I'm born in 65 that's 20 years after the Second World War.
20 years ago I was at ABC overhearing down ABC News.
I mean,
God hears is nothing anymore.
That's Seinfeld.
Seinfeld was on the air in 93 right.
So think about that.
That's so recent.
That's the Holocaust.
That is amazing.
So the people that lived in the sixties were dealing with such a strange time,
first of all,
the introduction of psychedelic drugs into the community that had never existed
before.
Right?
LSD and the proliferation or did in the late fifties with Huxley and those
people and then and the,
and the Kero acts and all that,
and then burst into mainstream.
And unbeknownst to most folks,
even though marijuana has been illegal in this country since the 1930s LSD
didn't become illegal until 1970 they pass this sweeping schedule,
one psychedelic act where they,
they made everything from pod to mushrooms,
all these different sacramental and few gins.
They made them all illegal.
They made them illegal then cause that was the first time law enforcement around
the country.
It was running into widespread problems with it and they didn't know.
There's a great drag net from the old drag nets that are so funny to watch.
The one,
the one with blue boy,
the most famous one ever is the,
you know,
those were were all based on actual things and this was the,
they find out people are using this brand new drug called LSD and there's no law
against it.
So immediately the first thing they had to do is go find a new law that they can
put into place.
It's like I say today,
the problem with our drug policy is that we're not accounting for the fact that
we might come up with some darn good drugs that don't do as much damage as the
ones we have.
Our policy will be to make whatever new drug we find illegal tomorrow.
If it intoxicates you,
it's illegal.
I don't know how much longer that's going to work,
but if I was the government trying to stamp out drugs,
I think I'd just make better drugs that competed with WWE.
I mean,
how do you,
how do you get rid of bathtub gin?
You get Bombay Sapphire and nobody wants any bathtub gin anymore.
Also,
you have to address what,
what's being done with these drugs and what's the effect because they've made no
effort whatsoever to stop things that turn you stupid.
There's no effort whatsoever to slow down oxycodone and oxy Maton vicodins well,
math sort of.
I mean they go after and make you go crazy.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
What I'm saying is the,
the,
the cover,
the government is not trying to stop a hydrocodone from,
I think they are.
They're,
they're,
they're passing laws now that say,
um,
oh there they're going after the hydrocodone.
Tough.
Now I'm brand new stuff.
They're going to,
you're not going to be able to call in a prescription refill for that.
You're going to have to have a physical prescription now every time they're
going to crack down on that big they are,
they are now.
I was,
um,
I was in Florida recently and a,
I'm thinking of hydrocodone.
Yeah.
I don't know if you know the situation in Florida,
they got a lot of the,
the,
the prescription doctors there.
Yeah.
They have pain management centers and what a pain management center is.
You go in and it's one building and like,
like this office and that door is the doctor you got hit me,
I fuck my backup hurts.
Our calc can't sleep.
Okay,
here's some oxycontin.
I guarantee you that five years that will not be around guarantee.
I bet you're right.
One of the reasons why is because it's been exposed and because there are time
when he documentaries.
Yeah.
The um,
the,
those guys from current TV,
I think it was current TV,
true to one of those fucking channels.
Vanguard is this the,
uh,
the show,
they had a show called the oxycontin express and what they did was essentially
they showed that there's a highway that connects Florida to the rest of the
country,
Ohio and Kentucky and Ohio.
And these people just getting busted with,
we're just going to say like Tennessee,
they just sit on the side of the road and bust any,
yeah.
Yeah.
But here's the thing,
I'm not convinced.
I mean,
when you look at,
if you look at modern society and you say,
where have we made the most technological advances,
you would have to put pharmacology in the top three or four areas,
right?
Yeah,
sure.
And when,
when,
when for example,
when the Nazis wanted stuff to keep their soldiers awake for things like,
you know,
unlimited blitzkrieg attacks and fighter pilots,
they would simply go to the pharmacy companies a,
here's what we need.
And they'd produce it.
If we were intelligent about this,
we would say as Doctor Weil so famously wrote 20 years ago,
people want to change their consciousness.
Can't we arrange for substances that do this in a more Safeway than the ones we
have that come with some pill that will sober you up when it's time to drive
home?
That's better than what we have now and I guarantee you if you said the pharmacy
companies,
and by the way,
we'll give you the patent to this for 20 years afterwards,
they will come up with something recreational better than anything we have,
but because of an almost,
I don't know if it's a puritan ethic or if it's the companies that make the
current products that are legal that don't want competition or whatever it is.
Nobody even talks about this.
This is nothing drives me crazier about the way we conduct things in American
life.
Then we don't even bring up subjects.
I don't mind if we come up with the wrong answer in a national debate on
something like this,
but can we have the national debate?
Can you come up and defend to me why we shouldn't be working on safer,
healthier alternatives if you're going to make this drug illegal for
recreational use,
no problem,
but give me something that people can use cause they want to use it that will do
something similar,
will be less harmful to the individual using it and less harmful to society.
I don't think that the government has any plans whatsoever on either backing or
or supporting any pharmaceutical company that creates psychedelics.
I think there's a big difference between creating hydrocodone
or creating a safer amphetamine or creating safer drugs that allow us to
continue to society as structured.
When you start getting into things like mushrooms and LSD and acid,
the real problem is the boundary dissolving properties are these things which
make you want to absolve.
Society made you want to get rid of all the laws,
makes you want to sleep naked and each other's floors and do a lot of like
culturally unsanctioned shit and that creates chaos.
And that created the chaos of the 60s.
It was a paradigm shifting sort of a way that people were looking at the world
that was impossible for the 1950s minded cops to control.
I think it's more of a difference between medicinal and recreational.
And I don't think the authorities,
whoever that may be,
have ever acknowledged that besides alcohol,
there is any such thing as recreational.
Um,
unless you accept the idea in a free society that may be people should be
allowed to use recreational stuff.
I used to say there ought to be a system,
a test,
right?
And it should be something like a hundred questions.
Question number one,
how likely is it to be addicting?
Question number two,
how dangerous is it?
Everything should pass this test.
And if you get above or below,
I don't know how it works.
A certain score,
you're legal.
If you don't,
you're illegal and you,
you put the current drugs that are legal on there too.
You put alcohol on there,
put caffeine on it and let's see how it scores.
Do you really think marijuana is going to fail that test and alcohol is going to
pass.
Um,
if,
like I said to you before,
if somebody invents the perfect drug tomorrow in some bath tub somewhere,
our government's going to ban it the day after tomorrow with no testing,
no questions asked.
Just on the grounds that it's recreational,
you're not allowed to have any recreational drugs.
Not only recreational is there's an issue with things being recreational,
Zo things,
anything performance enhancing,
you know,
pro vigil.
Do you know what pro vigil,
I don't know what pro vigil is like the latest smart drug rage amongst the
silicon valley set and it's a,
it's very odd stimulant that I'm not qualified to describe them.
The mechanics and the mechanism behind what it does.
But what it does is it gives you this sort of stimulated,
accelerated feeling without feeling like you're on speed.
Your heart rate doesn't go up,
you don't get jittery.
What's the action?
How's,
how's it,
what's it do?
Does it,
is it,
is it an amphetamine thing or no,
it's a new thing.
[inaudible] vitamin that just,
no,
no.
It's much more intense.
It's Brian,
you've experienced it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I was trying to zero sleep and I had to drive to San Diego.
I mean,
I could barely keep my eyes open and I took it and just immediately I was like,
oh,
I'm awake.
Okay.
Clear.
Do you know what it is or do you just take it sight unseen?
Well,
you got it from me.
I take anything.
I gave it to him because I didn't want to.
We have to have a laboratory situations.
He's,
yeah.
Um,
well let me,
um,
let me find the exact mechanism behind it.
So,
uh,
is it legal?
Yes,
absolutely.
Is it legal because they just haven't gotten around the band question
it.
Here's rather the,
uh,
the issue.
It's a Pr,
it was created essentially to
enhance mental performance and clarity.
However,
to get it as a prescription drug,
you can't have something that just makes you better.
You have to,
something wrong with you.
So they had to say,
uh,
narcolepsy,
narcolepsy.
It's the narcolepsy.
Absolutely.
I'm not bullshitting.
This is,
it's how do you prove you have narcolepsy?
I don't know,
for the doctor's office and just shamelessly shift work,
sleep disorder and excessive daytime sleepiness associated with obstructive
sleep apnea,
which by the way,
I have sleep app and it is not an amphetamine.
No,
it is not,
despite extensive research into the interaction,
it's called Modafinil.
That's the actual chemical name with a large number of neurotransmitter systems.
That precise,
precise mechanism or mechanisms of action remain.
I was going to be a dopamine serotonin kind of thing,
but it doesn't crash.
You don't crash afterwards.
It elevates hypothalmic histamine levels,
uh,
leading some return researchers to consider that Modafinil is a wakefulness
promoting agent rather than a classic amphetamine like Stimuli.
Are they using it on the street yet?
Oh yeah.
Well,
for sure.
And people in school,
people in startups,
people that are forced to work long hours on casters,
podcasters.
It can if you're exhausted and you had to take a,
uh,
like if you had to do something to try to wake up,
it's amazing what the fungus free coffee doesn't work anymore.
So let me ask you this.
What's the penalty for being caught with this stuff without a prescription?
Well,
being caught with any chemical,
the w the prescription is a misdemeanor,
right?
Isn't it?
Depending on how much you have and what the prescription is,
yeah,
you have to have a prescription,
but you can get one.
You know,
you can just say you're tired and you'd get one sleep apnea.
How can we,
I mean if you said,
think about how you would change the country if you said,
listen,
there's,
again,
getting back to my Joe Friday dragnet thing,
cause this is apparently how I learned about all this as a youth.
I remember the marijuana episode where,
where the guy is that the family man,
remember the one where he,
his child dies in the bathtub later.
We're where he's trying to argue with Joe Friday about why there's nothing wrong
with marijuana.
He says,
he says,
well,
it's less,
less effective than alcohol.
It doesn't,
doesn't bother you,
Joe.
Friday says,
but look at all the problem alcohol causes.
Do we really need another drug that does that?
I think that's how they think.
I think they think that you're going to increase and they might be right.
Try to fatalities.
I think a the wrong and B,
they don't really think that everything we've said here is about how they're
wrong.
So,
well,
I don't,
I don't believe they're right about chain about traffic fatalities.
I think people are safer drivers when they're high.
I think they drive slower.
They're more aware,
especially if they smoked pot on a regular basis.
It might depend on how high oh yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean obliterated.
You can get obliterated toward the point where it's reality dissolving.
I think if you legalize marijuana,
I think you would see more.
Uh,
I,
I think it's almost unequivocal.
You would see more,
uh,
what would you call it?
Nom Ui is what would you even know?
And I think you'd say more merging,
more waving.
Both allow you to merge.
You might listen to that.
There's no question that this stuff would come with a cost.
The question is,
is the cost that you would pay worse than what we have now?
I don't agree that it would come with a cost.
I think it would be beneficial to society as far as a relaxing.
I think if there's anything that society needs right now is a change of
perspective,
something to calm them down and more creativity and those are three things that
are promoted by her.
I think you're speaking as a guy who's,
who's experienced with this,
I think remember what it's love for what you get kids first starting out with
this stuff.
I look well,
kids should be educated.
Everything.
One of the thought of the problems with kids starting out with this stuff is
that they're going into it in an ignorant way,
experimenting on their own and no one knows what the,
what the effects are going to be.
No one knows what to expect because how every kid gets understanding about
alcohol.
I mean it's going to be a similar kind of a learning curve down my now my kids,
I teach them,
I speak to,
to drink,
well I don't let them drink,
but I speak,
but I have a 16 year old and I talked to her about alcohol varies.
What do you say?
Well,
first of all,
I tell her whenever,
whenever we have
conversations about anything,
one of the most important things that I bring up is all the things that I fucked
up.
They don't care about data.
Oh,
of course they do.
How many do you have kids?
Yeah,
two.
Two.
How old are they?
11 and eight when I,
when?
When I was a kid,
one of the things that I remember more than anything was a,
I have a really cool uncle,
uncle Vinny,
and one of the things that he would eat,
it seems like you believe uncle Vinny,
but he's actually an artist with long haired Hippie.
Um,
he,
when he would talk to me about things,
he would always talk to me.
Like if I did anything wrong,
it was always what he did,
how he fucked up first.
My father's famous line was do as I say,
not as I do.
He was a film maker.
So,
oh,
that's funny.
What I learned a lot listening to this guy tell him and I remember thinking like
that like he did.
He kept me from being on the defensive by explaining to me that it's just part
of human nature to fuck up and to make mistakes.
And because he was so honest about that,
I would listen to all of his advice,
whether it's about alcohol,
whether it's about whatever.
And I think the most important thing you can give to a kid is information and
love.
And the only way they're going to accept it as it,
they trust you.
And the only way they're going to trust you is if you're a hundred percent
honest with them all the time.
And you just,
you don't play any bullshit games with them.
And you explained to them,
and even not just not just honest,
but you got to explain to them all the times you fucked up as well.
So what do you do if I saw something the other day where Snoop Dogg is smoking
weed with his kid?
What about that?
Well,
how old's his kid?
First of all,
I don't know the answer to the question.
I mean if his kids a dog man,
that is,
that is right there.
The limit of my knowledge already.
So I'm off in the deep end here already.
I think the younger the better.
I think stone kids or would be awesome.
It's actually not good for your divine.
I was just going to say,
I'm living up in Oregon where there's a whole generation of kids that were on
Lsd from like five years old and he turns you into Courtney love without the
creative Portland,
Eugene gene.
Okay.
Portland look conservative does,
it does make fun of the conservative.
That's Hippieville central.
But God,
it's a beautiful country up there
from here.
So I mean,
coming back here is like,
you know,
I was telling my mom just today,
um,
this town feels claustrophobic to me.
You know,
we have like nine buildings where they used to have one on a lot and you just
feel like,
I mean,
I,
I need some outdoors areas.
You've got to go to the beach.
Yeah.
You don't realize how s smothered yard.
This town used to be a great place to live.
No offense.
A Angelenos.
It's still great.
It's just too big and crazy.
I live a little bit further out,
but I,
I want to move even further out.
I've,
I've actually been looking at Santa Barbara lately.
I really like is called in Santa Barbara though.
I'm not scared of the cold.
I grew up in Boston.
This is called is for pussies.
Boston's really bad.
That's brutality.
You're right.
Um,
where were we at?
Oh,
we were talking about them making drugs,
legal,
that the idea is that it's a personal freedom issue and the personal freedom is
you're a man.
I should not be able to,
if it was only two people on the planet,
just you and me.
And I said,
well,
I've made a law and the law is no alcohol.
You know,
he'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
There's only two of us and I want to drink.
You know,
well,
I'm going to lock you in a cage if you drink the alcohol.
It sounds preposterous,
but it's just as preposterous for 3000 people to,
to,
to tell 300 million people that they can't have pot.
Well,
here's the difference to me,
what's the difference between locking somebody up,
you find with the drug than locking somebody up who does something they
shouldn't be doing when they're on the drug?
I mean hold them accountable and responsible.
Then we're still going to have a ton of people in prison,
but they're not going to be in prison for possession.
They're going to be in prison for doing something that,
you know,
you go back to the old west and one of the standard stump speeches that the
person they were about to hang would give you.
The guy you know,
was about to hang,
would always feel,
not always,
but a lot of times feel like they needed to give some sort of lesson to the kids
and they'd say something like,
well,
you need to do avoid alcohol and don't end up like I ended up.
And that was,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Look,
that's going to happen.
Then there's no question that,
that I think it,
whether it's alcohol or anything else that's going to lead some people to
straight,
they call it a gateway drug.
Anything as a gate with the first thing you use is a gateway drug.
At the same time,
we punish people now for the potential that they might do with the illegal drug
if you punish him for the actuality.
I'm not sure it's any less effective than what we have now.
And you increase the overall freedom level.
Um,
you know,
the,
the idea that the founders had that we ought to use the states as laboratories.
This is where you get to the marijuana situation right now.
I would love for states to be able to actually try this out.
Instead of us having to have a national,
um,
experiment,
you know,
where everybody's sinks or swims together.
Let Colorado try this weed thing out and let's see how it goes.
I don't think the feds are going to let this really happen.
Um,
but to me that's the intelligent way to do it.
What do you think's going to happen with Seattle or Washington is going to be a,
there's going to be a showdown point and they're,
first of all,
the Fed's already aren't letting this happen.
I mean,
you know,
the,
the state and it puts the state lawmakers in a really weird position because
they're supposed to listen to the will of the voters.
And yet state law is trumped by federal law and everybody knows that.
So how they're supposed to act as a nether world.
The feds have never given one second of,
of lip service to the idea that they're going to allow this.
They always say,
well,
we're not going to concentrate on individual users,
blah blah,
but they do nothing
and the way they say that,
it's really just to sort of relax.
People are okay and then they move in.
I don't even think they're trying to relax people.
I think you've made it clear that they're going to go going after individual
users at least makes people think if they said we're going after everybody.
Everybody was smiling upon us when if the feds ever gone after individual users,
they don't know that the FBI doesn't come and arrest the guy smoking weed on the
corner.
Yeah,
you don't have five guys break into a house.
It was a joint selling joints and that's what's,
and that
they're just going to be a come up.
It's a moment and I don't know if that's going to be because one state goes one
step farther than everybody else and that's when you get knocked back.
Or if we get a new president in there and the first order,
but you know,
I don't,
I don't understand the forces at work that keep this stuff illegal.
If I understood that better,
then you would know,
okay,
what's it gonna take to Piss off that group too far?
You know,
is it the alcohol lobby and when do you go so far?
I don't,
I don't know who's keeping this stuff illegal.
So it's hard for me to pin down what the,
what the,
what the moment of going too far it's going to be.
But as we talked about earlier,
if they don't crack down at some point,
this stuff is going to become legal by default.
You know,
it's gonna,
it's gonna grow into legality where we've got these fig leaf laws on the books
that prohibited,
but nobody pays any attention.
Well,
you know,
logically there's no reason to stop it from being legal and their idea that it's
somehow going to harm the interests of the people that are profiting from it
being illegal.
I think it's silly.
It's not going to harm alcohol.
People are still going to drink.
People enjoy drinking.
It's fun for people.
It may limit some prescription drugs because there's going to be natural
remedies,
especially like interocular pressure being cured by cannabis and people with
wasting disease and aids that have issues with nausea and it's one of the best
things for nausea.
What happens when the people who have a lot of money invested in pseudo legal
marijuana start donating to the federal legislators?
That's a good question.
You'll get the,
the corruption working at cross purposes to the way it's working,
right?
Well,
the way they've stopped that is you're not supposed to be profiting from it in
California,
the only place where you're supposed to be profiting from it.
Ironically,
it's Colorado.
Colorado allows medical mirror the way the law pass the medical laws in Colorado
were different than the medical laws in California.
They allowed profit,
whereas in California it's supposed to be like a nonprofit.
I wonder how much of this has to do with the fact too that it's the equivalent
of being able to,
to distill your own alcohol,
your backyard if you want to.
I mean you take,
you take all of the companies that you might be able to get on your bandwagon
here at Philip Morris could make your marijuana cigarettes as opposed to
they have now where you'll just grow it in the back yard and nobody in the
house.
I mean the crazy thing is such a durable plant.
It's not like something like a tomato where you have to have good soil and you
have to make sure that you tend to do it and these things grow with you want
them to dialed in all 50 states.
I read something,
if you drive out the window and throw seeds out the window and come back in a
month,
you're going to see plants.
They just,
they find a way,
those little fuck.
Well then we get back to the,
what we talked about earlier about trigger points.
You know,
when do people rebel?
When have they had enough?
What if
you get high?
That's what happens when you get some LSD and then they rebelled when the
government
down and May and you know,
like if they go into Colorado or if they go into Washington or one of these
places where the vote,
the will of the people has been amply,
uh,
a red enacted into law and the whole thing and they overturn that,
that's going to be,
those are going to be interesting,
uh,
trigger points or benchmarks in,
um,
wherever it is we're heading.
So,
you know what they'd been doing the way the DEA has been handling it and
California is very fascinating.
They go in,
they break down the door,
do whatever they got to do guns in the air,
pulled people in the ground is a video of them stepping on some kids neck
college kid just working there.
The cop steps on his Nestle scene walks over him for no reason.
They smashed the security cameras.
Okay.
They thought that the cameras were on set.
It was actually sent,
but through the Internet to a third party location always.
So,
uh,
they got video of this where they tried to destroy it.
The cops tried to destroy it.
They steal all the drugs,
they take all the marijuana and they steal all the money.
Then they say,
we are holding a your file until we decide what to do with it.
And they do nothing.
So they take thousands of dollars,
whatever the fuck you have on,
on,
on the premises,
they take thousands of dollars in marijuana.
They'd take all of your,
you know,
all your cash on hand,
everything that they want to take from you.
And then they say,
we're holding your file,
we'll,
we'll tell you what we do when we decide.
And they can hold onto it for years and years and years.
So essentially they put you out of business,
they put you out of business without arresting you.
So are they enforcing federal law?
SORTA,
but they don't.
Are they enforcing state law?
No.
So it's not a state law,
it's just the federal law,
but they don't actually do anything about it.
They're very few people were actually getting brought to trial.
You're saying,
if you look at to what,
what the,
the,
the excuse for the militarization of police forces over the last 30 years has
been,
this drug war has been the greatest thing that ever happened in terms of,
for example,
search and seizure laws,
um,
departments.
I mean the idea that someone thought up,
hey,
wouldn't it be a great incentive to tell officers that they could get,
well,
there's actually some great books about this.
Dan Baum wrote one called smoking mirrors wants,
there are others where,
where there used to be two kinds of forfeiture laws,
a criminal one and a civil one without going too deeply into it in order to
fight the drug war.
During this crazy time of the 80s they decided to combine the two taking the
lower standard required for one kind and the higher penalties for the other kind
of putting them together and is where you got the situations where if the police
officer's burst down your door and found drugs,
they could seize your corvette automatically without any sort of a,
an acknowledgment that the corvette was bought with drug money on the grounds
that you have to sue us to get it back.
You have to prove that there was no drug money here and if you don't,
if we get to keep this car and sell it,
at least some of that money,
some departments got it,
all others had to share it with other agencies.
Some of that money goes right back to the people who seized it.
Now this was supposed to be a great incentive,
right?
Well we're going to crack it on the drug users and we'll be able to afford the
narcotics teams cause they will pay for itself.
But as Radley Balko is written in a book that's due out anytime now,
I saw an earlier version of it,
this has exploded the number of cases where please do these things and it comes
at the expense of robberies and other crimes that don't actually benefit the
department as much as these search and seizure drug crimes do.
And if you got rid of the drug crimes,
what happens to those departments that are making a bunch of money off of it
now,
do you know about the scandal that's been going on in Tennessee?
You mean the I the the interstate?
Yeah.
I'm all on top.
The cops for folks who don't know,
there's this thing they're doing,
they,
the police have this policy called policing for profit.
So they pull you over,
like Save,
you're a truck driver and you live in your truck and all your money in the world
isn't that truck.
What if you have $50,000 and it's in your truck?
You know,
they pull you over.
They say,
why the fuck do you have $50,000 they take your money and that's theirs.
Now you have to prove that you got that money through legal means and the way
Tennessee's doing it is,
apparently they'd been doing this for a while.
They've been,
they've been seizing money and that money goes to their,
their,
their police force.
Let me defend those people for a second though because one of the things that
doubt Balco his book had that I found fascinating was remember a lot of these
people are elected,
a lot of these shares,
for example,
are elected and there was one county,
I don't remember where it was,
where the sheriff was not going to do this,
and the guy who ran against him for sheriff said,
do you know how much money we're missing out on?
We're cutting officers left and right enforcement because we won't just go and
do what other look up at the county next door has.
They've got all this equipment and all these officers because they're seizing
assets and we're not.
In other words because the feds do not come in and enforce the constitution
because they allow this because it's,
remember before the war on terror made everything okay if it was part of the war
on terror,
the war on drugs allowed us to rip open parts of the Constitution on the grounds
that this war was so important and that were so many lives at stake.
And like the mafia,
it was so resistant to normal,
you know,
law enforcement techniques that we needed special tools that the federal
government not only allowed this stuff but encouraged people to do it.
And I would like to say proudly Los Angeles with Police Chief Daryl Gates in the
old days was one of the leaders in this when he would,
when we had the first tank,
I remember we had the first tank to knock down,
you know,
the,
the drug buildings and everything else and seize the,
um,
once that becomes standard fair,
are you going to be the sheriff that says,
I don't do that.
When the guy running against you says,
look at our idiot sheriff,
he's missing out on all these federal dollars.
Plus the Fed,
the Fed's actually match some of your costs.
They will hand you down paramilitary stuff as part of like used war surplus and
everything else.
I mean when you see these police officers in full cammo gear carrying ar
fifteens and everything,
a lot of that stuff is hand me down right from the military.
And if you don't want that,
you're going to run around with a stupid cult 44 revolver when you could have an
ar 15 and a tank.
What kind of bad sheriff are you?
Joe Rogan.
I'm a,
uh,
you know,
believe it or not,
but what I'm saying,
uh,
or some of the things that I've said,
I'm a big supporter of law enforcement too.
I think it's very important.
I think it's a,
they're underappreciated and it's not their gig.
The actual officers on the street don't make these rules.
Exactly.
And I think most of them are good guys.
They have the hardest job in the world.
It's really difficult.
He,
you're protecting people from bad people and it's a,
if you're going to have bad people,
you're going to need cops.
The,
the issue is one,
one bad one exists.
It makes it,
it's like,
you know,
it was 110 people in New Jersey.
Douchebag,
probably not even,
it's probably like one out of 20.
But when you think about jersey,
think about Douche bags.
It's just,
and what the laws,
I mean the cops just enforce the laws.
They don't write them,
they don't make them,
they don't decide what's constitutional,
what's not.
And it's also,
they're dealing with fucking bad people all day long.
Every day.
They're dealing with people that are too many crimes,
trying to get away with things,
lying to them,
constantly shooting at them.
When I was a reporter,
we had a lot of,
um,
you know,
you develop relationships with these people.
Um,
and you do it at the weirdest times.
I would go out to these murder scenes.
It'd be like four in the morning in the rain.
You're seeing the same guy,
you know,
the same watch guy you see all the time in the field and,
or you call them.
When I was at ABC here,
I mean,
I used to do the,
the beat checks.
They're called a news,
which is where you call all these police divisions and you're talking to the
same poor guy.
It's midnight and I'm calling the same guy how you do.
And I,
you know,
I mean they're just working schleps like the rest of us.
And you know what,
how many of us would perform any better after five years on the job with guys
shooting you?
That insane pressure.
It's insane pressure.
But again,
to get back to the people who are really responsible for this other people,
we elect that and boat wall.
It's also,
I think that as a society we have to put much more emphasis in our schools and
much more in our police force.
I think police,
fire,
EMT and schools,
it's the,
there should be so much more money
dedicated to these areas so much more.
And it's,
it's really,
uh,
a crime of society that we've allowed our politicians and the people in office
to allocate so much resources to other parts of the country while ignoring the,
oh,
there are problems that we have here at home.
I don't think there's anything wrong with help big out less fortunate countries,
but the way we do it under the guise of military invasion and the amount of
money that goes to that and where that money goes and you look at how much
Halliburton has made off this fucking war and weapons manufacturers for me
enough this war that is really a,
a criminal misallocation of funds.
I was recently,
and this is a weird story in and of itself,
my listeners know about it cause I did a show on it.
I was invited to a Centcom US Central Command planning session not that long
ago.
They flew me to DC.
Yeah.
Put me up in a hotel.
I thought I was assured that they were going to kill me and throw my body into
Potomac and this was all an excuse to get me over there too.
You refrained from jerking off in the hotel room because he felt like was a
camera.
Yeah.
Uh,
I assume there was a camera in there.
Um,
do you want to Cameron,
Eric,
but went in there probably more of a time problem I was dealing with there.
I was very rushed but I,
but you arrive there and it was all these people with these amazing,
I said they must have been thrilled to have me on the guest list because there
were only 12 participants and they all had these massively doctor,
this and that from this institution.
And then Dan Carlin podcaster and it was just,
they had to be thrilled.
I was there.
But the first question I asked these folks,
I mean it was the,
the,
the general that was there was the head of US Central Command.
The vice admiral was there and I said,
what are us taxpayers get from all of this?
In other words,
if we're going to go cost to benefit and you talk about vital us national
security and this,
that or this other area,
what is the average us taxpayer who's paying for this get for all of this?
Now there was no good answer and it's not these guys job to answer it.
They don't make policy.
They're like cops too.
They don't make policy,
but you want to ask your representatives,
you know,
I mean,
I know you say we need to be here and there to protect our security,
but really what does the United States,
from what I get from our involvement in the Middle East,
the oil situations,
not like it was in the early seventies we're not going to be,
there's not going to be petro blackmail like there wasn't the old days.
It's one big giant oil market.
Now why do we get to be the people to pay for this if it's,
if it's for the entire world's sake,
why isn't the entire world paying for,
why aren't their soldiers dying in the field as much as ours are?
I mean these are the kinds of questions we talked earlier about why can't we
have a national debate about this?
I don't care if the answer comes from the wrong side of what I consider to be
right or wrong,
but let's just talk about it.
And I have this conspiracy theory that the reason we don't have these national
debates is cause some of this stuff is just indefensible.
It's the same thing with President Obama trying to say it's okay to kill
Americans with drones.
You don't hear him talk about it cause I don't think you can get up and make
that case.
And so just don't talk about it.
If you can't win an argument,
don't have the argument.
Yeah.
That's the reason why I've never heard a politician bring up cigarettes.
You'll hear politicians talk about alcohol or drugs and even prescription
medications being issues.
You never hear him talking about cigarettes ever.
Why?
Cause they spend billions of dollars to keep politicians from talking about
cigarettes.
You know,
hundreds of thousands of people die every year from cigarettes.
He would think that's a real health issue.
No,
it's obesity.
We've got problems.
You know,
we've got problems with cancer,
we've got problems with AIDS.
We've got,
we have problems with the
fucking some poison that they sell at every corner.
But the people that sell that poison,
kick it back upstairs.
But this is nothing new.
This is part of how,
I mean,
listen,
as I said to somebody else,
and by the way,
I should say I'm before cigarettes.
If you want to smoke cigarettes,
I don't know.
I think cigarettes should be illegal.
Stop talking about cigarettes.
But,
but listen,
I know I'm not trying to stop people except my friends.
Every country in the world is corrupt.
Don't,
don't think that there's any government,
me,
Sweden,
which,
which always ranks in the top three or four is the least corrupt nations of the
world still has corruption there.
Why,
why Swiss chicks are hot?
It's,
we're talking about Sweden and the two confused,
but we dish every country has been corruption.
There's a tipping point as Sweden's number one on your list of I confused those
two.
Well,
if you go there,
they won't be any confusion.
Um,
if you have the number one least corrupt country,
Sweden and that,
and the per the country at the bottom of the list is Nigeria,
I guarantee you that government can function well a certain distance down that
list.
There's a tipping point,
I think if you say,
well,
do you know the United States has always been corrupt?
Look at how things were in the 1950s.
Yes,
but we were still able to function.
You know,
the corruption was not so much of,
it's like if you have a physical impediment and you say,
well,
I limp around,
but I still get around.
Okay,
and your knee gets much worse and all of a sudden you can't walk.
There's,
there's a tipping point not walking as a whole different thing than limping
around.
Right.
Our government was always corrupt from the very beginning of the republic.
We've just reached a point where it doesn't function any well then it's so
corrupt.
It's also that it is not just that it's so much more corrupt than ever before.
It's so much more transparent that it's corrupt because of our access to
information,
which is unprecedented and people are bewildered by it more than they ever have
been before because of this,
because if you go look and it's really simple,
just go looking real quick.
Read any Matt tie.
He be article from rolling stone on on the financial crisis and you'll,
you'll,
you'll fucking pluck your eyebrows out screaming in the mirror.
You,
you won't be able to feel,
you won't be able to feel like it makes any sense.
Let me tell you that this is the great wildcard though.
We alluded to this earlier when we talked about what at the sixties generation
had had the internet.
Um,
you know,
when you read about how much just printing presses change the world in terms of
just being able to disseminate English language bibles changed everything.
This w you know,
people forget,
you know,
he's like you said 20 years ago,
it's like a blink of an eye when you've lived a while.
This internet is still brand new.
We haven't begun to see what it's going to do yet and we haven't had these
situations.
Like you were saying,
these little tipping point moments where all of a sudden the Internet makes all
the difference in the world.
If the stupid printing press changes the world to the degree that did,
what's this going to do and how are the authorities going to react when it
starts to doing it?
I mean,
you know,
we were talking about anonymous before the whole show started.
That's just the tip of the iceberg.
What happens when this isn't some little teeny group on the fringes that's doing
this?
What happens when 40% of the population is so mad and maybe 20% of them are the
right wing guys who think that they need the guns to stop the government.
20% of them are the left wing guys that are so mad that they can't get,
you know,
something else that they,
I mean what happens when all these people are operating at cross purposes and
the Internet is this highway that lets them all talk in a way that during the
1960 [inaudible] they would have been doing mimeographed letters on a copy
machine handing each other than by hand meeting in the park and this foam soap
box and on the phone.
I mean this is,
this is,
we have not yet begun to see what this is going to do.
Change.
I agree.
And I also think that this is just the beginning of what seems to be an ever
increasing access to each other,
access to information,
the ability to reach and connect with each other.
And I think that's going to eventually lead to something that's going to allow
people to read each other's minds.
I think we're going to,
we're a,
our eventual connection is going to be through some sort of wireless and neuro
frequency connection where we're going to be able to exchange information
without having to talk to each other.
I'm sorry.
You see,
you see the upside and that I see the downside.
What happens with the government reads your mind and it's,
well,
we just bypass.
This was just something,
it's too dangerous for an individual to have,
but we'll be able to watch you on your computers.
Government will become victims of themselves,
much like portray.
This has become a victim of this whole spy network and the ability to access
information that's been on
precedent.
I'm sorry it was betray us.
An idiot.
Can I just,
can I just say this?
You're the head of the CIA
and you think that they're not going to find out that you have it.
I mean,
this whole thing,
there's,
you talk about something weird.
There's something,
there's some little x there that we don't know about.
It's Ben Gazi.
Yeah.
Ben Gazi.
No,
for real.
I haven't figured out the Ben Gazi thing either.
I haven't either.
But there is connection and that's,
that's pretty much been established that they are there.
They're shielding by one of the things they're doing with punishing,
betray us in this way and going after him is acknowledging his failures in
Benghazi and the,
there's a sort of an internal motivation to get rid of him outside of just the
fact that the FBI busted him with an affair.
What I found most fascinating about this was first of all that the head spook
got spooked on.
I mean they,
they,
and,
and then that even when you're a general,
you're dealing with the kind of girl was going to fuck you when you're married
is crazy bitch.
Okay.
And the kind of chick that's going to be your,
your mistress when she writes a book about you that that's going to be a
territorial,
yeah,
that's a Greek tragedy.
And that goes back to him either a Greek plays that play off.
That's why I love it.
There's something that's so wonderfully,
you know,
we all have these tragic flaws and it's like that guy was born with that and
then he was like faded.
The Greeks would say,
it was like written into his faith that I'm going to have this wonderful
military career,
be respected by everybody and then I'm going to be brought low by so silly.
Bring yourself to the world of Oj Simpson.
I was just talking about that with my wife the other day.
We're watching them,
one of those top 10 footballs,
you know,
greatest running backs of all time road and they're screwing poor Oj Simpson.
Nothing he's but,
but as a football player,
if you remember how great he was and you know,
they're putting like Tim Teebo or something ahead of him.
I'm going,
you know,
he's just getting rooked because of what he did off the phone.
It's like,
yeah,
you can get me get mad at,
you can get mad at,
uh,
at,
at Pete rose for being,
you know,
a,
a jerk off field,
but don't,
don't,
don't take away what he did on the field.
Oj Simpson was the most beautiful runner I ever saw.
Barry Sanders was the most exciting,
but Oj Simpson was the most beautiful runner I ever saw.
And he's a,
I mean he's one of the,
I mean he's a terrible person.
We all know this now,
but God,
don't,
you know Oj Simpson was was the best and what a world changing moment for him.
Yes.
To Go.
What a bad decision.
You know,
I could go back and take it back.
I know you think about that all the time.
The one moment that if I could just have that day or it's a groundhog day thing,
if I could just do that whole day differently.
The betrays thing.
Even though it's bad,
he still gets to bang that chick and she's way over AA still gets the pension.
That's all you care.
Cause he's still get his bomb shit.
Well maybe not the CIA one,
but he gets the military,
they have to give him a pension or he's going to start talking.
What do you want?
You want general Patraeus start writing books about shit really works.
I think that's when you have your Kennedy moment again.
General Patraeus knocked off in a visit to Guatemala.
Yeah.
He's banging his mistress and her pussy explodes.
He's going to put Nitroglycerin in there.
The,
the how you're off in the woods for me,
rogue going into territory.
I don't go to kill her too because this is Cheryl.
We knew this was going to happen in this show today.
Didn't we?
Pillow talk terrorism.
That's what that is.
It's in the Patriot Act.
She,
uh,
she can't see who's doing pillow talk,
terrorism.
We had to take her out and uh,
we,
it's unfortunate Patraeus was there but we clowned him so don't worry about it.
The poor guy.
And the whole thing is,
what's really tragic is you see the wife and you know,
his wife is sort of,
you let herself go over the years and I believe she had some health problems.
She's a little rather large.
Remember in the military I think you can still be charged with adultery to which
you can't be nobody.
There is no law against adultery in the California penal code for an average
Joe.
What's ironic about that is she taking trained killers,
putting them in an unbelievably stressful situations for months at a time away
from their wives.
And you're saying that if you're an adulterer,
we can court marshal yet goes back to the military code of honor,
which of course there's a lot of other things you could do that would seem to
violate the military code of honor,
but don't have,
you know,
don't have adulterous affairs.
I just thought it was beautiful that the head spooked got spooked on.
I'm sorry.
No,
it's not.
It's not that to me that's a symptom of something else because he's not a dumb
guy.
And yet what you're going to do when they arrive and they said,
guess what?
We found out?
Do you think he was shot?
Oh my God.
How did you find out about that?
No,
I'll tell you what it is when,
first of all,
they were together for over a year while they wrote that book.
Okay.
And when you know,
you can start off with a girl who's attempt trust,
like how you've analyzed this,
I've analyzed this very carefully because that woman is marked much,
much more attractive as a woman than he is as a man.
Uh,
but he's a man of
power.
Oh wait,
that happens all the time.
She does.
She do in with him.
That's Susan Anton and Dudley Moore.
I don't know.
Well he's,
he's powerful.
He's the head of the CIA and she obviously in writing a book about that is,
is fascinated by that subject.
But I think a woman like that,
if she has access to a man like that,
he,
he's going to break.
It's just a matter of time.
It's a matter.
He's going to decide this relationship is not working out that well and he wore,
he's going to decide it's something missing from his wife.
I love her as a friend,
but it's just,
I don't know what to do.
Power thing.
I mean these guys,
I think there's this,
this,
you get this sense and you see it with,
with celebrities all the time.
This sense get right back to Oj Simpson that I can get away with anything.
Um,
I'm,
I'm not regular this,
that only applies to normal people.
Well think that comes from a lot of people around you that are in a support
position that are constantly catering to you and kissing your ass.
I get it all the time.
Are you kidding man to man?
As you see a bar,
a vast staff here,
number of women you have circulating around here?
Yes.
Um,
the,
the celebrity thing is probably tenfold when you're dealing with a military man
who's a trained killer,
who's been responsible for leading armies to battle.
Oh.
And they live like puff daddy.
I mean,
they have limousines and I mean,
they have the generals live very well.
I don't,
I don't mean to begrudge them anything,
but if you get to the level of general,
it's quite a lifestyle.
Um,
yes.
And,
and it's just as attractive a lifestyle to some outside entity as any other
celebrities.
Like you're not quite Elvis,
but you know.
Yeah.
And again,
you're,
you're dealing with a man who's revered,
who publicly was a hero portrayal.
I mean,
that was the military guy that you heard of.
General Petraeus.
Petraeus is moving the truth.
Patraeus is doing this.
How different is this from Clinton?
Because I always think with Clinton and Lewinsky,
what are you an idiot?
Do you really think,
first of all,
do you really think that girl's going to keep her mouth shut?
You know,
nobody's going to find out.
I mean,
to me these are,
these are flaws.
Like I said,
like a Greek tragedy because the minute you fall for that,
you're done.
I mean,
how can you be so smart in every other respect and yet not there?
Well,
Clinton is a freak and I don't know if you know freaks,
you know,
any freaks,
any real freaks.
I suppose it depends on the definition.
I have friends that are freaks.
I have,
I have dudes that you could,
you could count on them doing something stupid if given the opportunity,
everybody in every other way,
they can be gifted and yeah,
they can be brilliant.
But when it comes to checks,
some guys just are off.
I could see that.
And I think Clinton is a freak.
I think you might be writing those dues that would just pull his dick out.
I think Clinton,
I think he did many times.
I mean,
that was the state trooper,
the uh,
the police.
What was her name?
Oh,
what's a Paula Jones?
Paula Jones said he's whipped and guy.
Why don't we just pull Paula Jones out?
That's how big of a deal it was at the time.
Well,
she,
she is fascinating to me too.
She eventually went on to do house,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
okay.
What was the other,
who was the blonde?
Remember the blonds?
There was some Blonde Jessica Flowers.
Okay.
Yeah,
I will,
I could,
uh,
yeah,
I,
who's the chick that sent Gary Hart?
Uh,
hold on,
I got that one that was,
um,
I carry Hart was,
oh,
so now I'm going to Jim Baker.
I'm getting her confused as a John Jessica Hahn,
the,
Oh,
what was,
I'll come up with it.
It was the monkey business was the name of the boat.
That's another guy that,
that guy would have been president.
Remember when he did too?
He dared the media to catch him.
He said,
if you really think I'm having an extra marital affair,
come and find out.
And it was like,
okay,
you're an idiot.
Dope.
And they're like,
okay,
what did he think?
There was like the camera's only had,
look,
we are a hundred yards out in the water.
There's no way they could see it.
You're driving me crazy now.
It's like on the tip of my tongue.
Who this girl was.
Okay.
Wasn't Marla maples was it was some other,
what was her name?
Know Marla maples was the chick that was married to,
uh,
what's his fucking face?
I love with the show is descended to now we've gone from heavy duty Constitution
Saana Rice.
I wasn't there.
I wasn't close.
She was so hot though.
Again.
She's so hot.
How is he going to say no to that?
Like Gary,
Gary Hart was,
he had the same problem Clinton had,
I mean pussy.
They're from the John F.
Kennedy School of Government.
Yeah.
There's a picture of her sitting on his lap on the boat,
right?
Yeah.
And she's got no pants on.
She's got a long shirt.
It's like over the pants and she's got a drink in our hand.
Boom party time.
That's why he became a politician.
Bulletproof.
They'll never catch me.
If you think I'm having an extramarital affair,
tail me and find out.
And he was running for president while this was happening,
not just running for president member.
We had this conversation about how weak the competition was at the time.
Gary Hart was huge compared to the people he,
he would've been running against like George Bush senior or something and it
would have been like having a Kennedy run against Nixon.
I mean it would have been slam dunk.
You're in and he taught,
there's a man who blew the presidency.
It's amazing.
And probably correctly now in hindsight.
Yeah,
well probably for all of them.
I mean look again at Kennedy who was like one of our most loved president and
this gets back to your thing about 20 years and say,
do you realize how short a time Kennedy was in office?
I mean it's like two and him,
you said he was in the middle of his first term.
It would be like Barack Obama died three years ago or something.
I mean,
it's crazy how much the guy gets a lionized when you really didn't even know
what you had there yet.
Well,
I mean it's what James Dean,
you know when people die,
people love them.
Oh my mother even says today.
I mean you were just in trance.
She was entranced by the guy.
By James Dean.
No,
by Kennedy.
Well he was the first guy that seemed,
first of all to be a regular person.
He seemed to come on.
He was also a movie star was it was Nixon,
Eisenhower and John F.
Kennedy.
I mean he was certainly handsome guy,
but what I mean by a regular person was he didn't seem like a liar.
He didn't seem like a co like Nixon seemed like a piece of plastic.
It's like you're looking at a guy with a two dimensional mask in front of them
that never gave you who he really was and was just a slip rate.
He was funny too.
I mean if you listen to him and like off the cuff discussion,
right man,
fall down funny.
I mean he had this witty dry sensing.
I mean people were putty in his hands.
We haven't had a president that funny since.
We really haven't no nowhere near that high level.
I mean the guy was the kind of,
well and Frank Sinatra and all those guys used to party with him cause he
Kennedy was a fun guy on a bunch of different levels and they love themselves
and love themselves to posting.
Robert was the more serious of the of the guys.
And you know,
he had an older brother that was the guy they were really grooming for the
presidency.
Joe was his older brother's name and he died on a World War II mission.
And the family was like crushed because they'd spent all the time grooming Joe
to be the presidential guy and now of course they're going to have to go to
number two and number two was jack.
Wow.
He died on one of those missions where he was going to volunteer to take a
bomber into like some really hardcore clandestine thing and the bomber takes off
and it's like just in the sky and the whole thing just explodes.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So that's how,
and you know,
John was involved in that PT 109 thing with his bad back.
And I mean all those guys you think about what they did as lightweight as John
F.
Kennedy was.
Can you imagine Clinton out there on the PT boat and were award too?
I mean it just doesn't even reach it.
It was almost a requirement back then to be president that you had served some
ACA.
It really was.
It really,
it's amazing how that sort of change.
Wouldn't society accepted Bush?
Well,
the drug when they accepted the whole draft dot,
but you get to the baby boomers,
you're ruling out a heck of a lot of people and everybody went through that war
too.
That's the other thing.
How many people were you going to find that weren't in World War II and if you
weren't you in World War II,
you were a psycho or a flat foot.
I'm even flat footed.
Guys were making it into World War Two when he got to Vietnam,
it's a,
it got to be a,
it's so much different because people are like,
well,
it was a stupid fucking war.
It's a war we should have never been involved with in the first place.
Who wants to be in Vietnam.
You know,
if I,
I was alive back then,
I probably would have dodged the draft.
We still had people like that.
Carrie was there,
McCain was there.
And uh,
and yet guys like Gore who was writing in like the Stars and Stripes newspaper
in Vietnam when he was doing,
he was a journalist.
Yeah.
Military.
You're like the dude in a,
like a Matthew Modine and full metal jacket.
I don't,
you know,
I don't remember.
I actually saw full metal jacket.
So that's a bad night.
Matthew Modine was the,
uh,
you know,
the dude for vision quest.
The,
the,
he,
the guy with glasses,
oh,
I know who he is.
I just don't remember the role.
His role was a journalist.
He was over there a,
he went through boot camp and everything.
Like Gore.
His Dad was a senator and the whole thing was,
they were thinking about as his future politics will,
you know,
you'd have to keep the war.
You're going to,
what about your politics?
So he went and he got,
you know,
one of the cush jobs.
Vietnam is famous for that.
Well,
Gordon had his moment with a massage therapist claimed that there was more than
one,
actually more than that.
So that's his move I used do.
It's that careful side doors moves.
Yes.
You know these dudes that kept massages,
I
don't know turf off before you get your massage.
I have a better point again and it gets to that,
that being smart thing.
If you're in Gore's position,
don't you want to have like a third party witness there?
Because even if you did nothing,
aren't you opening?
You know why?
Why?
Because he wants to get jerked off and if there's a third party that you're not
going to get jerked off to make it a close friend and,
but here's the thing,
he's getting jerked off on a regular.
That's what I bet.
I think you need to have him on the show.
That's a poignant question you can ask him.
You know,
since I brought it up like that in the podcast on the Internet,
I'm sure he'll respond.
I'm sure.
I mean,
you know,
he has a Twitter,
he'll hear about this.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it'll be an interesting conversation,
won't it?
And I'll say to him,
first and foremost,
everyone likes getting jerked off.
It's nothing to feel bad about.
And if we were living in China,
that would be a normal part of your massage.
And once again,
we're in the woods now.
Rogan,
this shows taking a left hand turn the woods.
This is where we land.
I know,
I know.
I have ventured into the woods with 13 miles down a dirt road and your car just
broke down with a tarp to keep the rain out and we sleep under it.
Yeah.
I don't think there's anything wrong with getting jerked off and I don't think
he should feel bad.
I think if you're going to get a massage,
you're basically getting jerked off anyway.
I mean,
what do you,
what does a massage,
ice and deal with this guy?
Was any of this coming up with Tyson?
I didn't see the show.
We talked about,
um,
my,
uh,
fart theory of aliens.
We did.
We talked about some and he went there with you.
He's,
he's awesome.
I'm,
I'm pleased.
I don't feel bad anymore.
Oh,
you shouldn't feel bad.
The Internet.
We're grown men.
We're fathers.
We're taxpayers were law abiding citizens were allowed to talk about anybody
knows getting jerked off in a hotel room by,
I'm assume he's in a country where that's legal.
He should be able to pay that.
It's like,
what is it?
An extra hundred bucks.
What's the difference?
He rubbing someone's dirty feet and rubbing their dick.
You know,
some people would probably be happier to rub your Dick then you're dirty feet.
I wouldn't know anything of a,
you're just,
see my wife's probably watching this,
right.
I don't know what you're talking.
If I understand well,
I'm not saying that you should do that,
nor do I want it or need it.
When I'm saying is there's a man,
if the man wants to get jerked off and he wants to go to a hotel and pay for
that poor,
poor,
poor Al Gore,
unless his name is Petraeus.
Yeah.
Well,
he wasn't just,
he was getting his freak on 100% he was in a relationship.
He was in love.
That's why what happened was,
you know the whole story,
that other woman who's a also sketchy and sort of slutty on a dirty Washington
groupies.
Yeah.
What was her name?
That the chicken Florida.
Which one is the other Patraeus one.
I'm not up to speed on it.
Okay.
That's the whole betray situation.
There's two girls,
one girl who was in Florida who was getting emailed by the old light and she is
for sure.
And she's in that Group B group that goes after all the generals.
You're the general's wife.
What do you do?
And letting them go to the group he meetings.
That's what I want to know.
She probably doesn't know that there's together for generals outrageously.
I mean,
you know,
you don't want to let him anywhere near that.
Well this girl was a,
this woman was married and her and the husband were both like really into like
celebrity military functions and military parties and they would both
be into that social socialite sort of military social world.
So it wasn't,
it wasn't that cut and dry,
wasn't it?
Like the weirdest goes on more than you would think in those groups.
I happened to know some people that would have been astronauts had it not been
for going after the wives of people who are ranked higher than they were.
So I mean this,
this,
this stuff has been going on forever.
It's always going to go on.
You're talking about trained killers,
you know,
I have friends that,
we're in various branches of the military would tell me the wild,
crazy fucking stories about war time.
You know,
dudes,
you know,
hey look scans.
I mean these are just party,
state side with guys who aren't even at war.
I mean it's a culture by the way,
you don't know if you're going to die.
You know,
you're,
you're over there in involved in the scariest thing you could ever be involved
in an actual war.
Bombs and planes and rocket launchers and grenades.
And these are also hard drinking,
hard,
partying,
hard exercising.
Like I was just talking to one guy last night.
He's like,
we get up in the morning,
you run 10 miles,
you go work hard all day,
you're done with the day.
You go out and you drink as hard as you work.
You know what I mean?
It's sort of a cultural thing and you know what you want to let down after a
hard day at work.
My Dad works not as hard as those guys.
I mean if the letting down is in is in proportion to how hard the day was,
you know,
you're going to need a lot more beers than I would need.
Yeah.
Let Al Gore get jerked off.
That's what I'm saying.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Why you hating on Al Gore and John Travolta?
John Travolta makes movies about war and I think he should get jerked off to,
I think it's absolutely commiserate.
That's right.
Look,
it's not that it's commensurate,
but in order for him to play the role correctly,
I think he's got,
he was just research for a part.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
What else?
What do you want the guy to do to just pretend and to sort of fill in the blanks
with his lack of personal experience?
I think that's what it must've been.
Yeah.
Um,
lack of personal experience.
I'm just researching again.
What do you think about,
this is something that I really want to make sure that we touch on.
Um,
and bringing it back to Al Gore,
believe it or not,
but in a,
in a serious way,
the Hbo Documentary Hacking Democracy when over the issue with the Diebold,
uh,
you,
yeah,
the voting machines machines and how they can be influenced by a third party and
third party information besides the person counting the vote,
the person making the vote.
Third Party.
There was room for a third party.
And,
um,
they,
they talked about how disturbing that was and how it hit.
It had been engineered for that and they essentially said,
look,
it's,
you could,
you could rig a vote.
You could rig it.
Um,
what do you,
what do you think about all that?
When you mentioned that,
all I can think about is how is this flying under the conversation?
You want,
you want one of the,
okay,
if you want to get down on anybody,
let's get down on the journalist who aren't doing their job.
That's,
that used to be my profession,
these wimpy kiss ass journalists who want to hang out afterwards behind the
velvet rope,
but the people they cover.
The question to ask the president and the other candidates is everything.
What do you think about this voting machines?
Are you,
you know what you tell,
ask
them.
Let's get their opinion.
Make them come.
You know the old line was make them go on the record to these guys are able to
say basically on the sly,
if you ask me any questions beyond these five things I have on this list right
here,
you're never coming to another function again and I won't answer your question
anyway.
You won't even get the satisfaction of saying,
well,
I got an answer before I was kicked out of the room.
You don't get your question answered and you never get to come back.
And that works now.
I mean in the Cold War they used to cut some slack of the politicians on certain
kinds of questions and there were certain manly rules like,
I mean everybody knew John F.
Kennedy was having all these affairs and it was not considered to be proper to
bring that up,
which is crazy when you consider the potential for blackmail.
But nonetheless,
um,
that sort of stuff was off the record.
But you get some damn tough questions on other things.
We don't have that today.
And if you want to say,
how does the country get as bad as it does without anyone talking about it?
That's because our so called fourth estate who plays a constitutional watchdog
role in our system isn't doing that.
Our fourth estate,
that's what the,
there are three estates of government that are official.
You have the executive branch,
the judicial branch and the legislative branch.
Those are the three estates that work from inside the government and they're
officially constitutional branches.
The fourth estate is a term used to describe a non constitutional branch,
a nongovernmental branch,
the watchdogs who watched the government from outside the government.
And that's the meeting.
Well,
don't you think though,
that with this new access to information that we're enjoying because of the
internet,
what's also rising is shows like yours,
the young Turks,
you know,
people who are openly,
actively questioning every single aspect.
Yes.
But let me tell you the difference because you're absolutely right and thank
goodness.
Um,
and thank goodness you brought that up Joe.
but here's the difference.
We don't have access to the sea here.
When CNN officially cut their investigative reporting budget,
which is a joke,
and he would cause they weren't doing any investigative reporting worth a salt
anyway,
they got rid of the stuff that provides the basis of information.
I don't mean to CNN,
I mean everywhere.
The investigative reporting is how we,
whether you're talking about me or the young Turks or anyone else,
that's where we get our info that allows us to then comment on it.
I'm not out doing the investigative work that is,
you know,
um,
there's a reason that the very first amendment to the constitution protects
freedom of the press.
And it's not because someone thinks you have should have the right to tail some
celebrity for TMZ because we just have to know who they're dating on the side.
It's because this is considered to be of national import.
The country goes to hell in a hand basket.
If you don't know what's going on and really what's going on,
the 1970s are turning out to be the high watermark of American journalism.
When you look at what was going on,
then you try and run and go.
You can't imagine that happening today and that's totally the opposite of what
you normally expect.
Normally you expect everything to get better.
the 70s from a news standpoint was so much better than what we have now in terms
expos,
A's and people getting nailed and that's Pre-internet.
If you took that level of dedication to investigative reporting,
it's all the post Watergate era stuff when everybody was going in and the way
you made your bones in journalism was to try to be Woodward and Bernstein.
I'll tell you a story.
When I got my first job in reporting,
I went from here in la where I was working on the assignment desk,
know behind the scenes to work in,
in front of the camera and the first thing that happens that that makes you
upset as a reporter is they'll send you to like the dog show and the knife show
and all these things where you're going,
this is why I got into news.
I want some meaty stories so I get my,
I get my hands on my first meaty story.
Members of the sheriff's department call me up on the slide and they start
telling me what the sheriff is doing secretly,
right?
I jump on this story takes weeks to flesh this thing out,
It's totally non cost effective.
I break the story.
It's this big deal.
Everybody's on it and the news director gives me an award because he has to
because it's this big deal,
but then he takes me in the office privately and tears me a new one and says,
don't you ever do that again?
I said,
well,
what am I supposed to be doing?
He says,
now the sheriff is never going to give us a story again.
They're never going to talk to us again.
You just burned our bridge with them.
Well,
wait a minute,
the guys involved in illegal activities.
Yeah,
but there's 57 stories we need to do down the road where we need their
cooperation and now they're not going to help us.
That's what's happened.
And that's,
you know,
on the national scale it's the same thing.
They don't want to be Woodward Bernstein because Woodward and Bernstein are
getting another interview with the president.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a very,
very good point about how this whole thing sort of gets more and more complex
and more,
more so you can have the internet,
but if anonymous doesn't tell us and release cables of what's going on,
who did the investigative work to give us enough information for me to comment?
How do you feel about wikileaks?
I disagree with,
but from what I can tell from the angry emails,
90% of my audience on that,
cause I think he looked in a world of the 1970s if we could have a media that
used to do its job,
we don't need a wikileaks.
Um,
in a world where the media is not doing its job.
You do need to wikileaks and that.
That's what's sad.
I'd rather you could have a wiki leaks that didn't give out information that
none of us wants given out,
but you get the good with the bad.
I don't think anybody could have done that job except that one guy who got ahold
of that information.
I don't think it's a matter of,
you don't think that it was inevitable at some point that some group of either
hackers or,
or you know,
I mean that's,
I don't know.
I think
it was an inevitability maybe,
but I mean to do it illegally.
I mean when you're,
when you're talking about the journalism journalists doing their job,
if what really been interesting is if Bradley Manning had gotten those documents
in New York Times,
I wonder how they would have handled it.
What would they have done?
What wikileaks did and if they did,
would they be considered criminals?
Like he like Julian Assange,
you
say that because I just had a listener download an article for me about five
weeks ago cause I heard about it.
It was in the wake of the whole Watergate thing.
The,
the,
the head of the Washington Post gave a speech to all these big corporate muckety
mucks a couple years after that.
Trying to explain that,
that don't worry,
we're not going to get all expos a now this isn't gonna this isn't going to be a
trend of ours to bring down presidents and everything.
You don't have to worry and you can go actually down,
you know,
if you have a j store account or whatever with these libraries,
you can actually download the speech from like 1976 and it was a Katharine
Graham,
the head of the Washington Post where it was this reassuring thing to the powers
that be that don't worry,
the media is not going to get to investigative and we're going to make sure we
protect your secrets enough so you don't have to worry.
That's what wikileaks and groups like it don't do.
And the truth is,
is I think we can all agree that there are secrets that should not come out.
Um,
the government abuses this privilege over and over again,
but if it's really going to kill us service members for example.
Right,
okay,
I understand that.
But when you say anything's going to kill us service members,
so I mean that,
that when you abuse it,
you stop,
you lose me.
Um,
if the,
if the media and the government were doing their job,
you don't need a wiki leaks when they're not.
Is it better to have no wikileaks at all or is it better to have a wikileaks
with all its flaws?
I'm sorry if the government,
if the stuff that we're already finding out opens up such a window of importance
in terms of us understanding how the world really works behind the scenes.
I'm sorry,
to me that's pretty darn invaluable.
But you know,
I'm,
I'm biased as,
as a journalistic guy.
I believe in that kind of openness.
Yeah,
most certainly.
And I,
and I do too.
And I believe in it also for the people that are in,
in,
in power.
But a lot of my listeners don't,
I got to tell you,
a lot of them are conditioned,
I think conditioned to think that that's,
you know,
you're going to release important secrets and get people killed.
And I got a lot of flack when I said that I was in favor of wikileaks releasing
some of this stuff.
You can correct me if I'm wrong,
uh,
online people,
but I don't believe they released any names of anyone that,
who security hadn't already been compromised.
Well,
and to be honest,
we may not know,
but has the,
has the world falling apart since they did?
I mean,
I think,
I think we can see here it has an exactly destroyed everything.
We got to look into the mentality of the people that are in the military in
crisis situations like that.
A collateral murder video.
Well,
it's bigger than that minister,
diplomatic stuff going and,
and I mean,
come on.
The truth of the matter is is,
is you can only form a,
you know,
when you,
when you analyze news,
right?
You said,
Dan Carlin's during this,
the young Turks are doing it.
We're doing news analysis.
But that requires you to have enough facts to really analyze.
If you don't,
you can't give it an analysis that has any sort of value at all.
And wikileaks was providing context that the media used to provide.
Well,
I,
I think in,
in the,
in their situation,
I think their,
their position was so extreme having this secret files,
having this access to this one guy and having secret files down.
I don't know how the media could have gotten that in any other way unless it's
Bradley manning guy or someone like him offered that stuff.
That's how it would have been the,
and that's how it used to be.
What would happen is that we'll,
how did it happen for a Woodward and Bernstein?
You had a guy who was in the CIA,
one of the top people,
feet deep throat.
Who was that?
Oh God,
he died just a few years ago.
What they know.
Yeah.
They know who he is now.
And he was disgruntled and mad at being a,
not getting a promotion and all this and so he was feeding them this stuff that
he wasn't allowed to feed them.
And it's like,
it's like I'm the guy who,
uh,
Daniel Ellsberg who was involved in that whole thing,
the Pentagon papers.
He says today that Julian Assange is,
is the modern day version of him and that he could have been brought up on the
exact same charge as an almost was,
I mean,
to bring up the 1917 espionage act as a way to go after somebody in the modern
21st century world is to me an example of how desperate they are mean.
Here's all you have to know.
This isn't really about this or that individual losing their lives.
This is about how much scandal you would have if we really knew what was going
on behind the scenes and what are politicians gave the okay for
in the same way that Watergate was.
Yeah,
it's um,
it's so strange to me watching him in the embassy,
was he the Guatemalan embassy and just hang out on a balcony giving speeches.
You said Ross Perot.
I mean,
I'm not
sure.
Part of the problem here is that this guy is such a weirdo anyway.
I mean,
if you'd had the all American boy that it would be a lot harder.
You'd still find weirder stories.
But why is it always one of these guys where it's so easy?
Yeah,
so you know,
why do that?
Why does he have to help so much?
You know?
Have you ever seen the video of him dancing?
No.
I can only imagine.
You must see it.
Pull it up.
We can do that though.
The marvels of 21st of this studio has capabilities.
Mind doesn't have it.
Just want you to know.
Yeah,
we have youtube.
I'm looking at,
you can see me right now.
I'm looking up at Edmond Joe's wonderful monitor here.
Julian assigns dancing is one of the silliest things you've ever seen in your
life because did it get leaked?
Is that how we know about it?
It must've a rival anonymous from gets.
What about someone who wanted to put a stop to this nonsense?
Right?
Cool.
You're following this movement.
This is your hero.
Well,
that's a funny thing because we will judge you by the way.
You move your body to music,
which is why I won't do that on video.
Really?
That's why.
Because you want to be respected.
I know.
I don't want to be embarrassed.
There's any difference.
I am willing to dance at every possible opportunity to keep me from ever having
to be in any sort of a political
position.
Let's see.
Look at this.
First of all.
Okay.
How much ecstasy do you have to be on before you want to dance like that?
Did we lose it?
Is this,
we have the shittiest fucking Internet here.
It's getting fixed by the end of this month.
We're almost,
when is this?
Does anybody know where this is taken?
It doesn't matter if this was taken in a past life.
He's guilty and he's all by himself.
He's like,
yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Look at him by himself.
Imagine Ross Perot dancing like that.
He'd never be President Clinton.
Well,
Clinton's done that.
Yeah,
the club was a lot darker.
This is what the Clinton do before he shot his third load.
It goes out there to get a little exercise.
I've just,
I'm sorry this,
this is part of the problem though.
I mean,
you know Julian Assange Lens Lens.
What?
Look at it this way.
I would say,
yeah,
that is pretty funny.
It's not quite
gay.
It's not quite feminine.
It's not masculine.
Pretty damn good.
You like it.
Are you happy with it?
Yeah.
He's one of those crazy guys at the bar that dances by himself goes,
you don't take those guys home.
Who's taking those guys home and some poor girl rocks?
He,
his situation is hilarious.
If you know the story with what they're charging him with,
when everybody sees like,
oh,
Julian Assange,
you say,
well,
he must have been guilty of espionage.
She must've been guilty of leaking secrets.
He must be guilty of something bad.
That's not why they're after him.
Thereafter,
they're after him because he had sex with a woman.
Surprise sex,
and this is what folks don't understand.
The actual charges they've trumped up against Julian Assange are,
he had had sex with him,
one with the condom.
They were lying in bed naked.
He stuck it in without a condom.
Yeah.
The,
here's the,
here's the key.
He's,
he's sending,
his lawyers have said,
as I understand it,
that as long as he gets a written pledge from our government,
the British government,
that they're not going to nab him.
He'll go back and face the charges.
The key is,
is everybody knows that those are the governments that wanted it.
The danger isn't that he's going to go to Sweden and face these charges.
The danger is that somebody is going to disappear him.
That's right.
And he's given a dissident and the government would like to do that to set an
example.
The problem is,
is one,
he's not an American citizen.
So what?
You can't charge him with the same things.
You could charge a Bradley Manning.
Would he become,
do you think you'd become a martyr if something like that happened?
Don't you think there's a danger?
You're already getting some of that?
Um,
yeah,
for sure.
I don't,
you know what?
I don't think the government cares too much about that.
I think their attitude is they want you to see what happens to somebody who does
what Julian Assange does so that you know,
if you do it.
I think the,
who was the guy who just died?
He just killed himself.
That the government was after for stealing files.
Aaron,
what was his last name?
The guy who killed himself was under pressure from the governor for stealing
some stuff from MIT,
some digital files.
I'm not aware of this guy.
Oh,
come on.
This is,
this is a big story.
The guy killed himself,
a big computer guy who helped create a child himself.
Aaron,
Aaron.
Oh,
I know who you're talking,
I'm sorry.
How can I forget his last time?
I'm going to ask the guy who was the responsible for the creation of RSS feeds.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah,
Aaron Schwartz.
Yes,
exactly.
I should have known that.
And,
and but he's another example where the government wants to break that guy as,
as to set a precedent so that you know,
when you want to try to do something like that,
you're sacrificing your life in effect,
in effect.
You know,
you can do this,
but look at what happened at the last guy who did it.
And that's,
I think what they want to do too,
with signage to,
to say to all those hackers out there,
hey,
you know,
just so you know,
you're playing with your future.
They've done this at the so called ecoterrorists too,
where they'll give you 35 years or something for,
for starting a fire where you can kill a guy and get out in 12.
And could they put you on no fly list?
Yeah,
you're done.
They'd do everything they can to sort of stifle your life.
And um,
the fact that we accept that though,
the fact that this,
this guy does not have the same access to a representation to rights that,
that we do that he's not an American start.
Start with that though.
I mean,
yeah.
Uh,
and not that an American
would either if you were accused of a crime of terrorism,
I mean,
if you're,
if you're accused of a crime of terrorism and you're in a place like
Afghanistan,
you have no rights at all.
If a guy in the executive branch of government decides,
well,
what a creepy sweeping term terrorism is,
if it applies to you exposing murder.
And just so exposing the,
whether it's an aptitude or just a casual disdain or,
or,
or just,
uh,
a lack of respect for human life.
And here's the thing you want to get into history and where history is
important.
Every time,
every is a sweeping word,
but many,
many times throughout history when someone wants to exempt people from the
normal rules of conduct,
you call them terrorists.
It's a term,
believe it or not,
Adolph Hitler used it when he was explaining why you didn't have to treat
captured prisoners in the Soviet Union with any sort of the laws of war.
They're terrorists,
Jews,
commissar has anyone found behind the front lines is a terrorist which exempts
you from treating them like prisoners of war.
I mean,
terrorist is a word that means anything you want it to mean.
And it's been proven to be that over and over.
Not that,
not that there aren't real terrorists,
but the term is so remarkably flexible and allows you to essentially how,
who can you waterboard you could only waterboard terrorist who's a terrorist.
That's to be determined.
We don't know who tomorrow's terrorists are.
We'll tell you when we get there.
Well,
terrorists are also defined as people sell drugs.
They've,
um,
because of all these different things that they passed the Patriot Act,
the Patriot Act to the NDA.
Well,
one of the things that they've done in these sort of sweeping definitions as
they've,
uh,
they've allowed the government to use things that were supposed to be there to
protect you from terrorism or to enforce laws against terrorism.
And now they use it for drugs.
Like for instance,
the Patriot Act,
the Patriot Act has been used rough more than a thousand times for drugs.
This is,
this goes way back though.
It's,
it's the old American Canard of the targeted extra extraordinary law.
Start with Rico.
Most people have heard of the Rico Act.
We use the Rico act against everybody in their brother today,
right?
The Rico Act is an extra constitutional law.
It was extra constitutional because when we passed it in the early seventies,
we needed to go after the mafia organized crime.
And the way this thing was sold is that organized crime because of their power,
was resistant to normal rules and approaches.
So you had to have special laws and it will only be used against organized
crime.
And the Mafia.
He was really the Mafia.
We called it organized crime,
but it was the mafia and because they were so specially powerful and so
insulated,
you couldn't get the top guys.
We were going to have a special law that just applied to them and just like all
these other special laws eventually becomes too nice and easy of a tool to start
applying it to other things.
We use Rico against two people in a room making a drug deal.
Now all but this is a long history.
Anytime they pass a special law that's extra constitutional because of the
extremity of the threat,
it always gets brought down to lower level.
When people don't understand,
if you hear about the Patriot Act,
go,
well guess that's a,
so they can stop people from plotting crimes against America.
The Patriot Act is used way more for marijuana than it ever has been for Teleco.
Wrote about this in his book too.
In 2011 the,
the,
the numbers were 1,618 drug cases,
15 terrorism cases.
Well,
you know,
there just isn't that much terrorism.
I mean it's a waste of a good law and that is a problem with having laws and
then removing laws that people have to be aware of when they talk about,
well,
hey,
they should just make drugs legal.
What are you going to do with all his DEA agents?
Were you going to do with those people that don't have jobs?
Back to the media thing,
how does the president not have to answer a question about that?
It's true.
How do you,
the the,
the fact that this all goes on confounds us because nobody ever has to comment
on it.
The job of the journalist is say to the president,
16,000 [inaudible] say exactly what you said and say,
what's your opinion of that and what are you going to do about it?
[inaudible] I mean,
you know,
you watch the British parliament in action sometimes on cspan and every time I
mentioned this,
the British,
you know,
podcasting is wonderful,
isn't it?
You have an international audience.
The British shall we say,
don't romanticize it.
It sucks just as bad as your government,
but to an American when you watch parliament than action.
And the head of the government,
the equivalent of our president has to get up there and actually defend his
policies to the hooting and hollering and borderline violence of the rest of the
people in parliament.
I'm done.
Forget about real reform.
I just want him to get up there and have to face the questions and hear how they
wheeze allowed.
If you throw that question,
like if we'd had a real debate during this last presidential campaign and you
ask Mitt Romney that question and us Barack Obama,
that question,
and it was asked by the way,
if you saw the third party debate where all of those interesting and sometimes
freaky people actually talked about the issues,
they brought this up,
but Barack Obama and Mitt Romney didn't have to talk about it because it wasn't
agreed to buy them in advance.
Get to that commission on presidential debates thing where they agree on what
they're going to talk about.
They don't want to talk about this and they never talk about this and they never
get asked this.
I mean,
how do you get away with two terms in office and you never have to answer a
question on that at all.
The commission for presidential debates,
for folks who don't know,
they probably own company as well.
It's not for Democrats and four Republicans sit on the board.
Um,
do you remember Jeff Gannon?
Why does the name ring a bell?
Yup.
Gannon was the guy who was an embedded White House reporter during the Bush
administration.
Any would lob these really softball partisan questions at Bush like Mr
President,
when are the Democrats going to wake up and come to reality?
Who did he work for here?
Here's where it gets crazy.
Uh,
I don't remember,
but what happened was people started getting suspicious.
So like,
who the fuck is this guy?
He's coming back to me a little going on with these questions.
These are ridiculous questions.
I mean,
these are over the top and obvious.
Even if plant no worse,
he was a gay prostitute and he was a man who ran a gig prostitute
site.
We did not see that coming.
By the way with him,
he had dog tags on and a towel over his genitals and he was like naked otherwise
and famously outed for this.
I just want to say I didn't know any journalist you don't run back in my day.
Well I remember this story.
I remember the guys name.
But here's my question.
Um,
what was the motive for softball and the president?
The question Ken.
Ken Lay mostly.
Probably.
Yeah.
Or you know,
who else wait,
somebody might say to take up one questioning position that wasn't used by a
journalist who would have asked a tough question.
Um,
that yes.
Also,
um,
I think there was probably some gay people that worked in the White House in
high positions of power that a wanted this guy around for various reasons.
And again,
no answer to that.
What is the name of bushes?
A key strategist.
What's that guy's name again?
Which key strategies?
The,
the,
the controversial guy that we believe that Mitt Romney won or lost the last
election.
Oh,
that was Carl Rah Rah.
He's a GOP stretch GOP strategist.
Famously.
Probably gay,
famously,
probably.
Right.
I know nothing about this.
If for lawsuit purposes and for lawsuit purposes,
I'm out of my fucking mind and on narcotics there's so much Kathy,
the fungus free coffees it to you.
I'm out of my head right now.
So that's not slander.
It's insanity.
It's not,
you know what,
listen,
Jeff Gannon,
I fucked them.
Oh,
a slander myself too.
You can't take anything I say seriously.
But this gentlemen,
Jeff Gannon,
he was a given credentials between 2003 in 2005 for two years.
He was a White House reporter.
He was a eventually employed by the conservative website,
Talon News,
uh,
during the latter part of this period.
So,
uh,
he was asking,
there were,
there were worried that he was asking questions so friendly.
This is in quotes that they might have been planted and this is how people were,
uh,
were,
were trying to,
uh,
you know,
look into this guy.
So they found out that he had some website.
Let me,
let me find the name of the website cause it's fucking ridiculous.
It's like a,
the super gay super,
super gay military website.
If anybody could see me right now.
My mouth is wide open though cause really I had not heard of this story and I'm
just thinking about what it took for me to get a press pass,
not to see the president and this guy had to be fingerprinted,
background check and the whole thing and made it through all that.
Yes.
Because he was someone's boyfriend.
I'm almost positive.
But you gotta be a lot of people's boyfriends cause there's a lot of people
you've got to get through to get to that gate.
Well he ran a whole website where he was,
had male escorts.
Yeah.
So this is like the Barney frank story where he's got the intern running the
house of prostitution and,
exactly.
That's funny.
Just check your head.
I mean it's not funny,
but you know what I mean.
Check by history.
Um,
I'll find his,
his,
his website here cause was,
it was like a richness.
Now that's my next question.
What's he do now?
Uh,
I think he's a blogger.
Coughing keys.
Got Congressman from Nebraska.
Um,
he came out in 2006 after it was all over,
but he was a $200 an hour male escorts cheat.
Yeah.
That's not a lot of money,
but you're dealing with a long time ago.
You're dealing with the two thousands.
Um,
it's,
it's quite fascinating because this is also something that really kind of
disappeared under the radar.
I gotta be honest with you and now that you brought it all up,
I don't remember this.
That's crazy.
I don't know.
And I can really informed.
I don't remember any of this.
Oh,
that's crazy.
How could you call yourself pretty,
you'll know about that.
I've been proven wrong actually.
I'm not following the right kind of newsfeeds.
Obviously the,
yeah,
they,
um,
they caught him,
because,
uh,
they,
you know,
they just looked into his,
uh,
his press credentials because people couldn't believe that the silly questions
that he was asking.
But you look into the press credentials before you actually get the press
credentials.
That's how it goes.
There's a,
there's a law enforcement person signature on the press credentials.
I mean I've,
I've done nothing really bad and my background and I remember sweating out me
getting press credentials,
I'm having a hard time finding the name of his website is,
this is an interesting,
but he had naked pictures on a bunch of different gay escort sites.
Well,
I'm starting to have real doubts about the secret service and the ability of the
background checks.
This is what year 2006,
2003 to 2005.
This war on terror.
Oh yeah.
This is wild.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's fascinating stuff.
I think he had a boyfriend.
I mean,
I think it's unquestionable.
Do you remember when that,
um,
madam in Washington DC,
uh,
came out with a whole list of different senators and she wasn't a Heidi Fleiss
thing,
was it?
No,
no,
no.
This is the DC Madam.
Then she turned out she committed suicide and all the,
all the,
uh,
the names disappeared.
Of course.
I remember the story.
Yeah.
That one.
I do remember.
That was on my RSS feed.
Yes.
I guess.
Uh,
she wasn't as good at keeping her mouth shut as this Jeff Gannon dude.
Or keep it in his mouth open or having enough secrets somewhere where he goes,
I got,
I've got Julian Assange is going to release this with a secret code if anything
happens to me.
Automatic.
Oh yeah,
please.
I don't want to ruin my great country by telling how many of you guys are
fucking each other behind closed doors.
Um,
yeah.
This was,
uh,
this was one of my favorite stories though,
about how you can't trust the press because who put the press into that
position?
Especially during,
I mean,
that was one of the things that people had commented about,
about the Bush administration.
Like,
wow,
this is the first time like,
uh,
an administration has been so transparent about its corruption,
so transparent about the influences that has,
has that,
you know,
the influences by Halbert and Halbert and CEO all of a sudden is now the vice
president and Halliburton's making billions of dollars in it and no bid
contracts.
I mean,
it was so obvious and corrupt.
And then here's this guy in the White House embedded White House reporter
lobbing these ridiculous questions and it turns out to be he's a gay escort.
I really think,
I think it's the war
on terror and the that that makes it,
you able to be so open about the corruption because what are you going to do?
I mean we have,
we have extreme wartime authority till the war's over now there will be no end
to the war.
Well here's the thing,
how can it end?
That's what I always,
you know,
one of the memes we had going on our show was was how do you end a war on
terror?
There is,
there is no way to,
there's nobody just surrender to you.
There's,
and if you called off the war tomorrow,
there's nothing that prevents the next president after some minor little terror
attack in any part of the world from calling it on again.
I mean if we really cared about the direction the country was going long term,
you would realize and a lot of good writers and constitutional law scholars have
that this is an open hole and things.
I mean you're allowed to basically suspend the constitution until the war's
over.
And yet it's one of those wars that,
I mean,
you can't say,
once we take Berlin,
everything goes back to normal.
There is no end to this and this and there's no end to what you can,
like you said,
no end to what you can call terrorism.
I mean it just,
it's like saying,
okay,
we're going to have a war on crime and as soon as it's over we can get the
constitution back.
Couldn't we just change the definition of terror?
Yeah,
but,
but that,
that's where we're going.
That's where we went.
Exactly.
Holes.
It's a war on tickling a,
he's actually a blogger now for the national press club for the weight from the
National Press Club.
Yep.
That's not a group of,
that's not a like side,
that's a pretty influential halfway normal groups.
Or there's an l in that club.
Is he a really good writer?
Is,
he's awesome.
It's sucking deck.
I bet he can turn a phrase really well.
And he's the Hunter Thompson of gay media.
Yeah,
the honor Thompson of gay media.
That's hilarious.
He should sell shirts that say that.
I'll leave that to you again.
You have the better ecommerce.
I should sell shirts.
I don't want his money.
He should sell shirts that say that.
I'm the Hunter Thompson of gay media.
Dan Carlin,
which will allow him to use it while she meant I'm,
it's making me out to be the Hunter Thompson.
No,
he showed wife will be so surprised.
That's confusing.
No,
that's not what I meant.
I meant you calling Jeff Gannon to a hundred times that of gay media.
If he shared,
but he can put it on a book jacket.
A blurb.
Dan Carlin calls him the Hunter Thompson of gay media.
Well he's out now,
so I guess he could.
He could,
you know.
Well I'll email them.
You got to staff here.
You people can even my staff is virtually imaginary.
Oh,
this is even better.
His professional name in the homosexual escort service was bulldog.
His professional name was bulldog.
Oh Jesus.
God helps makes bones,
but I don't know cause it's cause it's sexy.
No,
fucking bulldog is.
This is a picture of him from his website
for rail.
That was an embedded White House report.
Well and listen just for the audience out there,
it doesn't go well.
I guess you can.
It's not the homosexual thing.
It's the stereotypical,
I was a government plant in a,
I mean there's,
it is almost like a fiction.
Well it's also,
it goes back to the secrecy in,
in our government that for sure
someone in there,
I ain't for sure someone in there has a boyfriend.
I did.
Again,
why was nobody asked about this?
Can you please explain to me how he got the press credentials?
We can know all about portraying his girlfriend,
but we can't know how this guy got the press credentials.
I don't understand.
Yeah.
Nobody wants to ask
what about white wave?
But the reason no one wants to ask is because everybody else in government who
would ask this question,
who gets access is innocent and not gay like him,
but it's just planted people.
I mean it's like watching meet the press now.
Am I the only person that thinks David Gregory is,
I mean he's a softball pitcher.
Literally.
I mean watch this and you just go,
how is this satisfying to,
no offense,
NBC,
but,
but how,
how is the satisfy?
How has this,
I don't,
I don't understand media anymore.
The mainstream,
yeah.
Media's approach in the sort of con those conversation shows about a serious
issues.
It's like,
boy,
they,
they are softball down the middle lobs.
Everything is,
there's,
there's no real controversy when it comes to them.
Journalists learn issues.
A real journalist would look at something like Wikipedia and if,
if they couldn't support it,
they'd certainly have a soft spot in their heart for it.
If I recall,
mainstream journalism was horrified at Wikipedia.
That doesn't ring true to me.
But while you can't just publish these secrets thing,
well you have to do something.
Don't you?
Wiki leaks,
wiki media,
wikis.
He was sorted.
I thank you for clarifying that.
Baffled by why?
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
um,
uh,
I think,
access to information when it exposes crime is always good.
Uh,
if it exposes crime,
that's irrational crime.
You know,
I mean,
I'm not talking about like a beating off or something,
smoking pot,
something victimless crime.
But when you're,
when you're talking about real corruption,
corruption,
being exposed by a wiki leaks or being exposed by the New York Times,
which he should be upset about always is the corruption and you should praise
always whatever method of access to information has been utilized in order to
get it out to the people,
whether it's a website,
whether it's The New York Times,
it's like you should be happy that the New York Times exposes things.
You should be happy that Woodward and Bernstein broke Watergate.
I mean,
we should all be happy.
I think there's a simpler rule and the simpler rule is will we be worse or
better off with more information or less information and a great way of putting
it.
I have yet to find someone who can really explain to me that that tradeoff
argues in favor of keeping things secret.
Um,
somebody will say,
well,
we'll lose an agent in this or that city and that,
that,
that's a breach of trust.
And I understand that at the same time this country is dying from lack of
investigative journalism and uncovering malfeasance and corruption and all these
things.
You can't tell me that the protection of a source here or there outweighs what
we're seeing all around us.
So this weird thing that happened after September 11th where uh,
it was very scary to me where all of a sudden no one wanted to question the
government.
Everyone wanted to support the government,
the troops
support whatever hard decisions that had to be made,
but no one wanted to have any of the healthy skepticism.
That's why we have to have a cooling off period after the next one because
here's the way it goes.
If the experts say and they do that,
we're going to get hit again,
that it's inevitable that you can't stop it.
It's going to happen.
And if you know you are going to freak out when it happens again,
we're not talking about like a little teeny attack.
We're talking about another two buildings go down or there's a nuclear attack in
a harbor or you know,
pick your worst case scenario.
If you know that you're going to be crazy and ready to rip up the constant,
Hey,
we're going to legislate during a period of temporary insanity.
If you really want to save the country,
write some rules about that.
Now say we're going to be out of our minds.
Let's make some,
let's put some speed bumps.
Let's say you,
you can't legislate for 60 days.
Well,
you can close loopholes that let the terror,
you know that we found a loophole that led him in.
You can close that,
but let's not write any Patriot Act three until we've had enough time to calm
down.
What blows me away is the way that they sold the Patriot Act to us was by saying
there's a sunset clause.
It's gotta be renewed.
Right?
Don't be afraid.
This isn't permanent.
It's got to be renewed.
It's been renewed every time.
It's been renewed every time with no,
it's not even close.
Not only that,
most people are not aware that it's legislation that was written far before
September 11th but couldn't get past.
Peter Defazio's told me,
I haven't,
I suppose to say this,
maybe it would be.
He said,
listen,
a lot of this stuff,
you can't write a giant Patriot Act like that in the time it took to actually
write it.
He goes,
a lot of these were sitting on the shelf things.
I mean you think about a standalone laws and they just pick this stuff off the
shelf through it.
And what a lot of people don't know,
although this happens with a lot of laws,
is that there's a lot of blank spaces because people don't quite know how it's
gonna work out.
So when you sign these things,
you actually signed something with a lot of blank spaces because,
and this happens with a lot of us,
cause they don't know the specifics yet.
It's not that it's part of the scheme or,
or the trying to to slip something through.
A lot of times with these laws,
they don't know the mechanism yet.
They know that they want to get from a to C and they're not quite sure how be
works out yet.
But you sign onto the concept but you support C and we'll figure out how to get
there when we figured out how to get there.
And so they sign a lot of these things that have a lot of blank spaces and how
few politicians read any of those things they signed.
One of the things they've gone over is like the amount of paperwork that these
guys would have to read if they read everything they signed.
Yeah,
and it's,
it's impossible and they've said that they've,
they've openly admitted that,
you know,
there's no way anyone could around all this stuff in the amount of time you're
given.
We have to be able to read each other's minds.
Dan Carlin,
that's where we're going to fix this whole thing.
We're going to be able to absolve lies.
We're going to,
we're going to be able to stop all the nonsense as soon as everyone agrees to
the neural chip.
I think if you're going to have a lot of government people right on your side on
that job and they're going to be,
you know what,
that's just what we were thinking.
Joe,
come and work at Darpa.
The defense.
We've been thinking about how to read people's minds for a long time ago there
and they got robot dogs patrolling the perimeter at laser beam eyeball.
I think the bigger danger is they're already reading your mind and that's the
problem.
Yeah,
the big,
I always said like with clones,
you know,
like it's just a matter of time before they clone like
acumen,
hybrid slash.
Creatures.
Maybe that explains why the president's always change on inauguration day.
Maybe those aren't made me can imagine,
imagine if that was a science fiction movie.
They pull the president into another room and it's like an invasion of the body
snatchers.
Odd wait,
foaming and growing in the corner.
Yes.
I wonder,
um,
how
we're going to keep this sort of a very flawed system of float over the next
decade to,
isn't that what I said?
I mean,
it's,
it's harder to imagine you talk about revolution on one hand there's,
I don't want to call it fascism,
but let's just call it a more repressive kind of stayed.
On the other hand,
it's weirder for me to think of the spaces that we're in now continuing than it
is to imagine it going far off into,
I don't know which direction it's going to go.
I just can't imagine we stay in this weird Netherworld for another 10 years.
Feel that it's a,
the biggest resistance right now to governments right now is technological.
The,
the anonymous movement and the Wiki leaks.
But look at how they're cracking down on that already.
A lot of countries are,
I mean we've got,
I mean the only thing we tend to agree upon with Iran and stuff is that you need
a more controlled internet and those kinds of things.
And a lot of these countries are starting to try to form their own regional
internets that they can control and everybody will be cells and all,
all these tech guys will,
I can't control the Internet.
It was designed to avert a nuclear war.
And you know what?
I'm not so sure those guys are right.
They say that,
but the governments of all of the world are putting in so much effort to this.
I'm not so sure that then that's just going to switch us over to another
internet and then drown the other one in spam someday so that it becomes
unusable.
I mean,
I don't think they're going to,
I think the,
the,
the real issue is who are the most intelligent people?
What,
what side are they on?
The most intelligent people on the side of the resistance,
the most intelligent people in the side of the coders,
the hackers,
the people that are are writing software.
The people that are the,
the technological innovators,
they're not government agents.
Those guys are dummies.
They,
that's why they can hack into the White House.
Yeah.
Long term.
We talk about a five year old growing up today,
are they going to grow up with this kind of mentality we have.
This is the problem.
When you change the constitutional rights situation slowly,
the way we have is you begin to grow a new generation of people that never knew.
A pre nine 11 world for example,
that don't have the same feeling we have about loss of rights or any of these
other things because they've never known any better.
Are you going to get the next generation of people growing up with a hacker
mentality or they're going to be every bit as good on computers is our best
people are,
but come from a mentality that doesn't say,
oh,
what about our fourth amendment rights being gone?
And what about the,
they've never known any other world.
That's interesting.
I don't know.
Agree.
Um,
I know,
I think that children,
first of all,
almost always look at old people like they're fucking stupid and they've ruined
everything.
They might have a point and they might have a point and then you're,
you're,
you're growing up in this society that they created that they,
they've been running and they've been running shittily they'd done a terrible
job and running this government.
I don't think anybody's going to be like a super computer expert and be all Gung
Ho to his follow protocol as written because this government is a,
all wise and all knowing.
I don't,
I don't think there's any,
okay,
but,
so if you're the government,
there's two choices in your scenario and your scenario.
One choice is the revolution,
as you call it,
the resistance wins.
The other choice is that if the government wants to stay in power,
they crack down more and they turn us into something that's more repressive than
it is.
Well then it gets really tricky because who is the government when I guess we
find out Ben don't.
Yeah,
because when,
one of the,
my point,
one of my,
um,
one of the points of fascination that I had about this whole betray thing was
the fact that it was the government versus the government and I,
that was something that I was not aware of before that the FBI and the CIA don't
like each other,
which is
like when you get the corruption from the pro marijuana people putting in money
to campaigns and the now,
now you see things start to even out a little.
Yeah.
Well also in the marijuana world,
you see illegal growers who are against legalization because it would cut down
their profits.
There's people who are illegal growers who voted against medical marijuana and
that's cannibalism and it's,
those kinds of things are very interesting.
Yeah.
You're always going to have situations like that?
I think so.
It's uh,
I think the,
the,
the factions of the government can't agree on what,
you know,
who they are,
who they're for and who they're not for the fact that the FBI was willing to go
after the CIA and that's how this whole thing happened with betray us and he
got,
you know,
smoked out like that.
I think that you're,
you've got too many people and they're,
they're not a unified front.
They're not going to get together and say this is what we need to do.
We need to,
I think they will believe that they can pass laws to try to stop things,
but while they're doing this and passing laws,
technology waits for no one and these people don't understand technology.
These people are old.
These people that are in their sixties and seventies that are in positions of
power.
I do not think they truly appreciate most of them.
At least truly appreciate the power of the movement of,
of,
of free information on the Internet.
I don't,
like
we said though,
I think the key is going to be how the average individuals impacted by the
changes.
It's one thing to say,
hey,
my life's pretty good.
I'm going to still play video games.
I'm fine with my job.
When they get thrown out of their house,
when they can't make enough money to live,
when the American dream is,
is nowhere near within their reach and there's enough of those people.
I think all of a sudden the motivation changes.
I mean,
I had a friend who was a draft protester in the 1960s and he said,
the real sad part of the antiwar movement was how much of it was based on the
fact that I was going to be drafted and when Nixon got rid of the draft,
he did it cynically believing that a lot of people would then say,
oh,
I don't care about the warranty more if I,
if I'm not going to go,
I don't care.
And he was right.
And the the,
the membership that the people attending these anti war rallies plummeted once
those people weren't going to get drafted.
If you talk about people being impacted by a worsening economy and worsening
conditions and bad government decisions,
pay no attention to what the average American's lifestyles like.
It's like drafting those people.
All of a sudden people who had no stake in this care because they can't afford
food or they can't afford a TV and they can't afford cable or whatever it is
they need.
Well,
as we wrap this thing up,
how do you think,
if you had to guess,
I wouldn't want to ask anybody.
Well,
you're one of the few people that would ever asked this question.
How do you think it's going to go down over the next 10 years?
What if you had to guess what is a,
what's going to take place in this country?
I told you already my,
my big fear is that we're going to have another terror attack because I don't
see how we avoid that,
where we're at and it's not just the terrorist bombing were out there poking,
poking a nest.
It's all over the world.
I mean that's how people respond in a lot of these places.
And I think if we get hit again,
I think we're going to go crazy.
So you think it's going to be bad?
You think it's going to be like right after September 11?
I don't make,
I don't see enough positives.
I just don't see enough positives.
I mean I,
I'm hoping,
but I don't see,
I don't see enough variables that can break in the good direction and I see a
lot of variables that can break in the bad direction.
Do you think
summit we move,
we're moving towards a one world government.
I think that's a weird statement.
Loaded statement.
I don't know about one world government.
I think,
I think we're moving towards a government that agrees with a lot of other
governments about certain things and one is I don't think most of the world
governments are,
are happy about the Internet's ability to,
I mean they're fine with us watching cat videos and,
and having that keep us pacified.
None of them are happy about information sharing.
None of them are happy about that kind of stuff.
Uh,
[inaudible] context though,
the fact that everyone was so isolated for so long.
And then over the last less than a hundred years,
there's been this incredible interaction.
That's how the podcast,
you hit your heard all over the world.
Yeah.
Escalated.
And this is just people shooting the shit,
but just the,
uh,
the ability to translate into those websites and exchange information and kind
of understand that were absolutely revolutionary.
No question.
We're not much different than anyone anywhere else other than the environment,
culture,
all that other stuff.
But people want the same thing.
They want to be happy,
they want to be healthy and they want to know why the fuck they were in a war,
you know?
And maybe maybe some little,
sure.
Yeah.
Some of them do it better answer.
A lot of them do the ones who are going,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a little bit more a positive than you are.
Less cynical maybe.
I think a technological innovation is our savior.
That's what I really
could be,
could be.
I could see it.
I paid,
the variables are there.
I just see so many more on one side of the ledger than the other.
I do.
But I also see culturally so much more on the technological side of the ledger.
The fact that the Internet has provided
this open,
just this open platform that didn't exist before and much like a printed type
much like,
um,
the television radio.
There's,
this is the new burst.
This is the new,
I hope you're right.
Listen,
I'm all on board.
I'd like to be more positive and it really would.
Hmm.
Sorry.
I'd like you to be more positive to him.
He scared the shit out of him.
Okay.
That's my,
that's kind of look that nice job.
This was a fascinating podcast.
We could do this for like a hundred hours,
but I had a good time myself.
Thank you for having me any time.
If you ever want to come back please.
If you have anything you ever want to promote,
please let me know.
Tour the studio was worth the price of admission,
man.
A beautiful conversation.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Thanks very much.
And uh,
you can follow Dan on Twitter.
It's DC common sense and you all,
is it DC hardcore history,
art corps history.
Just go to my website at [inaudible] dot com download the podcasts,
whatever.
There's two podcasts.
I'm a common sense and hardcore history.
Both of them really,
really well received on the Internet.
My,
the guys on my board go crazy and the gals,
sorry ladies,
love it.
They're the big,
big supporters of you,
so I'm so glad we finally pulled aside my and mine.
People like you too.
Like I said,
I didn't know we had all the crossover.
It was really fun,
man.
I had a great time.
Thank you.
Sorry about all the exploding pussy shit and I hope it doesn't hurt anybody's
feelings that the two.
I'm sure it will be some interesting Twitter posts after the shelf.
Yeah.
Hey,
what are you doing hanging out with that guy?
Sorry folks.
I'm a comedian,
a rogan.ting.com go there,
save yourself 25 bucks off either a cell phone or service for a really ethical
company,
a cool company that supports our podcast and we love them also,
squarespace.com thank you Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com forward slash.
Joe,
try it out.
Use the code named Joe Too.
If you decide to use it and you will get 10% off your first purchase on new
accounts,
including monthly and annual plans.
It's an awesome website.
You gotta check out Squarespace.
It's really fucking bad ass.
If you're thinking about putting together your own website,
you can do it yourself.
You really don't have to have a professional crew do it.
Go and check it out.
I guarantee you it's so intuitive and you can make beautiful websites.
It's a really bad ass.
Um,
got a desk,
squad.tv for any information on upcoming shows that Brian has got going on.
He has a one coming up in San Diego at the American comedy company.
It's got Jason [inaudible],
who's a fucking hilarious dude.
It's got,
um,
uh,
Tony Hinchcliffe who's was a really funny,
witty up and coming guys.
One of the big writers on Jeff Ross Burn.
Billy Bono just was added and we're going to be announcing somebody this week
and now what?
What's that day again?
March 14th and the websites,
American comedy code.com.
It's a 10:00 PM show and the t shirts are all in stock right now at shop squad.
Oh go get yourself a desk.
Quad Kitty cat shirt.
And uh,
we are also,
uh,
Brian and Dunkin and I will be in Cincinnati this Friday night at the Taf
theater and then Columbus this Saturday night at the palace theater.
We're on the road.
You dirty bitches and we're coming up.
Oh,
hi.
plan some honey,
honey music,
kicking ass and taking names.
So we'll see you fucks.
And tomorrow,
um,
is a Duncan Trussell donkey.
Trussell joins us on the podcast tomorrow and then,
uh,
Eddie Huang joins us on Wednesday.
We're going to have some fun this week and we love the shit out of you.
Thank you for tuning in.
We appreciate it very much.
We appreciate all the positive love that you guys sent out there on the
Internet.
Who sent it right back at Ya.
And we'll see you soon.
Thank you.